in this comprehensive react course you
will learn everything you need to know
about react by building an e-commerce
website harsha is an experienced
developer and a popular instructor hello
guys my name is harshavadhan
i am famous udemy instructor mentor team
leader
and also worked as senior developer on
various front-end and back-end
technologies
welcome to the course of react for
beginners
let us see what kind of project we are
going to build in this course
this application is a smaller demo
application for practicing various
concepts of react
in this course we are going to build the
react application using class components
in react you can create components that
means pages in two ways
either with class components or
functional components
in this course we are going to use the
class components
but in my full udemy course we are going
to build the application
with functional components
for react beginners it is really
recommended to learn the react class
components first before trying to
understand the functional components
because in class components you will
really understand how does the rendering
process works
how can you share the data from one
component to another component
and how do you intermingle the design
logic and programming logic
once you are clear with the class
components then you will try to
understand the functional components
so exactly in this course we are going
to build this basic application on react
using class components
let us see what kind of pages we are
going to build
at first as you can see there is a login
form
once after you enter the email and
password values
if it is successful login
you can see the simple dashboard design
and this is the customers page
where you will learn about various
rendering techniques
such as rendering the buttons
rendering the images conditional
formatting etc
and also this is the shopping cart page
where you can increase or decrease the
quantity of the product
and also buy now in order to proceed for
the payment
that's all these are the pages we are
going to build
so what are the prerequisites to learn
this course
you require to know the basics of html
css
and
general concepts on bootstrap such as
buttons navigation bar etc
but in this basic application
we are going to learn various concepts
of react
you will learn how do you render the
lists
how do you render the methods
images and css styles how can you
communicate between the parent to
channel components
and lifecycle methods such as component
date mount etc
and also how do you create the forms
along with the text boxes etc
and also two-way binding
and then how do you interact with the
rest api servers by making http requests
and also basic routing
in order to create the page navigation
so by end of this course you will be
able to know what are the various
concepts in react and how do you build
the basic applications in react
so what is react
react is the javascript library to build
dynamic and interactive user interfaces
that executes faster
so like i said react is a javascript
library
it is not a framework
so what makes a difference between the
framework and library
a framework provides the complete
solution
for creating the front-end applications
but when you talk about react
being it as a library
it is the lightweight
it provides the support for building
only view that means only the user
interfaces for your application
but it is not necessarily a drawback
it provides proper mechanism to build
user interfaces
and to make them interactive with the
user
that means you can accept inputs from
the user
and also provide dynamic information to
the user
that's how the real world applications
work
for example you take facebook
it provides all the posts in the field
page
and also lets the user to create their
own posts
so this kind of user interactions can be
created by using react
react was developed by facebook in 2011
and it is mainly used for development of
single page applications
so what is a single page application
a single page application is an
application
that renders small pieces of user
interface
and make the complete application
in react you can actually build reusable
ui components
each component is a representation of a
meaningful page in your user interface
for example in a modern application
you have a navigation bar and the
sidebar as well as the page content
here each of these can be represented as
a piece of ui
and those are represented as components
in the code
and these components are by default
reusable
that means you can display the
navigation bar wherever required in the
application
that means for example
if you create a navbar as a ua component
you can reuse the same navbar in
multiple pages
wherever required in your big
application
so by default ui components are reusable
pieces
which consists of the desired logic as
well as the programming logic
here the design logic is written in the
form of html
and the programming logic is written in
the form of javascript
and by default these components are
arranged in hierarchy that is called
virtual dom
so a virtual dom is the hierarchy of the
components
which imitate the real dom of the
browser
when you update any changes in the
virtual dom
react internally compares the virtual
dom and real dom
and only the changes made in the virtual
dom will be updated into the real down
and the same appears on the browser
we will understand more about components
and virtual dom in the next lecture
but how to create the components
react supports a new syntax called jsx
which stands for javascript
with xml
that means the developer can actually
use
all the concepts of javascript
along with xml within the same program
here the html tags are written in the
form of xml
that means here html is being case
instead
and every tag should have opening and
closing
or they must be self closed
these are the features of react
what makes it exciting about react is
that
react is the most popular frontend
library or framework which is very
competitive to the other frameworks such
as angular or vue.js
but often react is compared with angular
so you might have a question such that
what is the difference between angular
and react
well angular is the framework
but react is the ui library
so react being as a ui library
it provides sophisticated solution to
make the ui interactive and dynamic
but angular provides much more beyond
these
in addition to ui
angular provides necessary features to
create routing and make rest api calls
in angular applications
so angular provides much more beyond
react.js
because react sticks to only view
it is not necessarily a drawback
but you can actually extend that means
use third-party tools in react in order
to use the features such as routing or
making rest api calls
angular forces us to build only single
page applications
suppose if you want multi-page
applications in your project
it is very difficult or sometimes
becomes impossible in case of angular
but react can be used for either single
page or multi-page applications
so before development of your
application you need not worry whether
it is a single page application or
multi-page application
eventually in the middle of the
development also you can convert the
single page application into multiplex
application
by creating multiple html files in react
but the same can be most problematic in
case of angular
angular directly operates based on real
browser dom
that means when you update a value of a
property in angular
the same will be directly reflected in
the real dom
rather than first operating in the
virtual dom
but in case of react
it directly works based on virtual dom
and every time when you make any updates
in the virtual dom
for example if you modify any property
value in virtual dom
it actually compares the virtual dom and
real browser dom
and updates the real dom
only for the specific change
instead of overwriting the complete dom
so this makes react applications work
faster
i will talk about components and virtual
dom in the next lecture
and another difference between angular
and react is
angular by default supports two-way
binding
that means it can actually read inputs
from the user
and also provides state data to the user
but when it comes to react it by default
supports only one way binding
it officially doesn't support two-way
binding
it actually can render state to the user
but cannot read the inputs from the user
but however developer can manually read
the values of the text boxes and update
the same in the state
in that way it can become two-way
binding
anyways we will demonstrate the binding
in the further sections
so these are all the differences between
angular and react
this is a good time to learn react
and necessarily you need not know
angular because we will actually
demonstrate all the concepts of react
so you don't require any prior knowledge
of angular to understand react
in case if you are not much familiar
about ecmascript 6
don't worry
as part of the progress we will
understand various concepts of
ecmascript
whenever we actually use them in the
code
so let's get started with react
and in the next lecture we will
understand what is a component actually
and how the component hierarchy is
formed internally
and after that we will really start
creating the react application
to make our hands dirty
let us learn what is a component and how
they work based on virtual dom
in react a component is a piece of ui
that contains the design logic and
programming logic
the goal of the component is
to read data from a javascript object
and render the same to the user
so it contains the design logic in the
form of html
it may include with any html tags
such as div or h1 or table etc
and it may include with javascript code
to make the ui be interactive with the
user
by default every application should
contain a root level component that is
called app component
eventually this app component may have
children
for example in the real world
application
we have various sections such as navbar
side menu and page content
and those are represented as chain
components
and by default these components are
reusable
that means you can really use the same
navbar
in a different page or in a different
application wherever required
because it is individual sophisticated
and isolated component
it is self-sufficient enough
to have the data in the form of state
and project or render the information to
the user
and each component can have children
for example the side menu has menu item
and page content may have grid
or signup page
and of course these components also be
reusable
so as you keep on nesting the components
the component hierarchy will be formed
where the app is the ultimate root or
parent level component
you can invoke the child component in
the parent component by invoking its
name
and this hierarchy structure of
components is called as component
hierarchy
and in this component hierarchy
the data can be shared among the
components
but only from parent to child
but not from child to parent
how will you create a component
by definition component is a class
and it contains substrate
that is the data that you want to render
to the user
so what data that you want to render to
the user
all that data will be stored in the form
of a javascript object
and that object is called as a state
for example in a food ordering
application
you wish to display the food item name
and price
so you will have that item name and
price in the form of an object
and that is called as a state
next it contains a method called render
method
this method tells react
how the state should be rendered to the
user
the render method actually returns a
react element
it contains the actual html tags
defining how the data should be rendered
to the user
a react element is a simple javascript
object
that represents a piece of ui
much like a dom element in javascript
but the difference is
react element is called as virtual dom
and actual dom element is the real dom
a virtual dom or react element is the
dummy representation of real browser dom
but making the changes to virtual dom is
super easy and lightweight
when you compare to real dom virtual dom
occupies very less amount of memory
and updates are faster in virtual dom
when you make any real changes in the
state of the component
react automatically compares the virtual
dom and real dom
and updates only the specific changes in
the real dom
instead of re-rendering the complete
real dom
for example in a component we have four
text boxes
and we have updated the state of the
first text box only
if so
react updates only the specific text box
value in the real dom instead of
re-rendering all the four text box
values
this makes react work faster than
expected
so what you can understand from this
lecture is
a virtual dom is a simple javascript
object
that reflects the real dom
and every time when you update the
virtual dom
the changes will be automatically
affected in the real dom by react
internally but it never overrates the
complete dom
at any point of time
so making updates in the state is super
easy and simple as well as lightweight
in case of react
this is how the react actually works
but this is all theoretical
but how will you really get started with
react
by creating a new
application that's what we will do in
the next lecture
we are going to build a simple web
application in react
in the next lecture
let's get your hands dirty by creating
first application in react
at first we need to set up the
environment which are necessary for
creating react application
first you need to install node.js
so you may wonder
why we require node.js
this is not the actual node.js course
this is the react course
the reason why we installed node.js is
that
for working with the package manager
called npm
that is node.js package manager
it has plenty of packages
and you require a package called create
react app
which is shipped through npm
not only that we need additional
packages such as babel
and webpack
that are shipped through npm
and this npm is a part of node.js
so that is the reason
why we require node.js for working with
react
in addition to this for execution of
react application also
you require a lightweight development
server
and internally that server is built
based on node.js
so that is the reason you need node.js
for working with react
so you can actually download and install
either current or lts version
but i prefer using lts
because the current liabilities of react
were already be updated with the lts
version
rather than the current or latest
version of node.js
so prefer using lts
and you will get a file like this
and run the file
and it's a simple wizard to install
node.js
and you can complete this simple wizard
by clicking on next next and finish
and after completion of installation of
node.js
you require to install the code editor
that is visual studio code
it is open source lightweight and free
to use
so go to code.visualstudio.com
and click on download for windows
and run this setup file it installs
visual study code for you
so after installing visual studio code
open the command prompt window
by typing cmd
alternatively you can also use node.js
command prompt
from the start menu
after installing visual studio code
this is the time for installing a
package called create react app
which helps us to create the react
applications easily
in order to do so
open the command prompt or terminal on
your mission
and use the command npm install
create react app hyphen g
that means hey npm that is not just
package manager install a package called
create react app
and install it globally
that means this package must be
available globally on any folder in the
same machine
so that you will be able to create and
run the react applications
from any folder on your mission
so run the command npm install create
react app hyphen g
it downloads the package and installs
the same on your local mission
and after installing this package
this is the time for creating a new
react application
but before than that let us create a new
folder to place our react applications
i am trying to create a new folder by
using md command
that means make directory
and specify the path of the new folder
that is for example sequel and react
with this name a new folder will be
created
and you need to locate the same folder
by using cd
followed by the folder name that is
sequel and react
so make sure you're in the correct
folder that is c colon react in this
case
and now
you need to use the command called
create react app
in order to make a react application
so create react app
space application name
the application name can be anything
but should not contain capital letters
for example i am giving the name my
first app
you can use hyphens for separation of
words
but uppercase letters are not
recommended
so run the command create react app
space and provide your application name
so this command creates the react
application
and automatically set up the necessary
development server
pebble and webpack
the development server helps us to
execute
react applications after compilation
and a webpack package helps us to bundle
the files
and the bubble package helps us to
compile the javascript files
from jsx files into regular plain
javascript files
so those compiled javascript files can
be really executed on the browser
and after creating the react application
you can use either of these commands
like npm start npm run npm test etc
but for timing you require one command
called npm start in order to compile and
execute the react application
so first switch to the application
folder
that is cd
sql react
my first application
so make sure you're in the correct
folder that is my first application
and run the command npm start
this will automatically compile and
execute the react application
in the default browser
in case if you want to change the
default browser
you can use the windows settings
and go to apps
this is the cool default output from
react application
but how does it work
let's edit the source code by using
visual study code now
in order to get started with go to start
and locate visual studio code
and go to file menu open folder
and select the appropriate folder that
is current
react my first application folder
and click on select folder
and in this folder you can see something
called public and
src the public folder you can see
index.html
this will be the starting point of your
react application
so it contains the typical html syntax
and it imports the icon and contains the
basic metro tag
and of course these meta tags are
optional
and if you scroll down
you can see something called no script
this message will be appear when
javascript is not enabled on the browser
because to execute react application
it is necessary that user must enable
javascript
but of course javascript is enabled by
default in all the user missions
in all the modern browsers
and we have a tag called div tag
with id called root
this due tag is the placeholder
where the actual react output will be
rendered at runtime
and after that there is nothing much
just closing of body and html
and now coming to the src folder you
have something called
index.js
which has a statement called react dom
dot render
and which eventually invokes app
that means it renders the app component
in the root element which is already
present in the index.html file
so where is the definition of the app
component
go to app.js file in the cersei folder
there you can see something called app
and it has a new tag that renders all
the relevant output
that we have seen in the browser
for example this rotating icon is the
img tag which is written here
and after that you can see some
hyperlink for example land react
which appears here
and you can make any changes in app.js
but in the next lecture we will try to
learn
how to build react application from the
scratch
then you will understand how these files
are working internally
now let's try to make some changes in
the app.js file to bring some output in
the browser
in order to do so let me arrange the
browser and vs code side by side
so this is the code of the app.js file
that comes up automatically
at the time of creating the application
so it has a function called app
in which we are trying to written
a div tag which contains some content
so let me remove this particular div tag
and
save the changes
and return something here for example
a deal with hello
the moment once you make the changes and
save the file automatically the page
refresh in the browser
so as you can see it shows hello
as the default output
you can use the control plus button in
order to increase the zoom
as of now the zoom is 140
we can use control plus
to increase the zoom
and we can use ctrl minus to decrease
the zoom
so whatever the html tag that you
written in this particular function
will be printed as it is in the browser
this is the default code setup
i recommend some preferences go to file
menu preferences
settings
and go to text editor
and then formatting
and check the checkbox format on save
so because of this checkbox
as soon as you save the file
automatically the code will be formatted
that means the code will be properly
maintained with proper indentation
and optionally i recommend an extension
called prettier
so go to extensions that means the fifth
icon on the top left corner
then search for prettier
and install this code formatter called
prettier
and then after that
come back to the app.js file
press alt shift tf in order to format
the file
or press ctrl s to save the file
in this case as soon as you save the
file automatically the file will be
formatted
for example if you give unnecessary
spaces here
and
not maintain proper indentation like
this
and upon saving the changes
the code will be automatically formatted
and also you make sure you add default
formatter in the preferences
to do so go to file menu preferences
and then again settings
go to open settings json
and then at last
make sure you set up the printer as the
default formatter for both javascript
and also for jsx files
okay let's close these preferences
now let's try to build the same
application from the scratch
without using the predefined files
so let me select all the files of the
src folder
and delete them
now the src folder is empty
but all the files of the public folder
exist as it is
and mainly
we have the index.html file
and the react compiler expects a file
called index.js in the src folder
so let's create the index.js file in the
src folder
so right click on src folder new file
file name is index.js
so this is the index.js file in the src
folder
in this
we are trying to create an element and i
wish to render the same into the react
dom
in order to create an element we are
writing where
element is equal to
some html tag for example
new
hello world
so
as we have set the default formatter in
vs code
as soon as you make the changes
automatically the file will be formatted
so you need not format the code manually
every time
now you can see an error called react
must be in scope when using jsx
which means that
this particular tag will be converted
into react.createelement
by using a javascript compiler called
babel
so babel is a javascript compiler
that converts the jsx syntax into
regular javascript
to demonstrate babel
go to beveljs.io
and click on try it out
so once you click on try it out
we are just writing some html tag for
example
p hi
the same will be automatically converted
as a reactor.create
element and the name of the tag here is
p
and the argument for the attributes is
null that means it has no arguments
and the content of the element is high
like this
whenever you write html code as xml
syntax
automatically bevel will convert the
same into react.createelement
this is also called as react element
this particular react element will be a
part of the virtual dom of the react
in the previous lecture we have
understood the virtual dom
it is the hierarchical structure of the
elements that you render on the page
you can notice that in the actual code
that you write on the left hand side
we don't have anything related to react
but once the bevel compiles the same
into javascript
it has something called as react dot
create element
it means that
this object called react must be
declared or must be imported
in this case we should import this
object
from a predefined module called react
and that is the reason even though we
are not using react directly
we must import react from react module
so just above the actual statement
you try writing import react
from react module
so we are importing an object called
react
from a predefined module called react
that means it is importing the object
from the module that is present inside
the node underscore modules folder
ok we need not worry about the node
underscore modules
these are already installed by npm
now save the file
now that errors were clear in the
browser console
now this is the time for rendering the
same into the react dom
in order to render the react element
into the react dom
we required something called as import
react dom
from the module called the react hyphen
dom
always the right hand side one is the
module name
and the left hand side one is the
default import of the particular module
so we are importing an object called
react dom
from the module called react hyphen dom
and make sure you write the correct
casing that is r must be upper case
and d o m dom should be the upper case
again
so
based on the same react dom object
we are trying to render the element
by using a predefined method called
render
so for this render method you need to
pass the element that you want to render
that is the variable name element here
that means it represents the value well
and after that you need to specify the
position or placeholder where this
particular element must be rendered
so come back to the explorer window
go to the index.html file
in this index.html file
we have a new tag in the body tag
with id equal to root
this is the placeholder where you can
render the element
remember it has an id called root
and based on this id we need to select
the element in the actual js file
in order to select the element
based on the id
we have a predefined method called get
element by id
in the plain javascript itself
alternatively you can also try using
document.queryselector
but in that case we have to write hash
before writing the id
so
document.getelement
of roach
will select the element that is present
inside the index.html file
and inside this particular div
we are rendering a due tag called
developer
and let me save it
automatically the page refreshes
you can see the output as hello world
that means
this particular element called hello
world will be rendered inside the root
element that is present inside the
index.html file
if you can notice
if you want to exactly investigate where
it is rendered exactly
you can use the browser developer tools
to do so right click on hello world
inspect element or inspect in chrome
it opens the developer tools
there you can see the new id equal to
root which was already present in the
index.html file
but dynamically the react element was
rendered inside the root element
so as a result of this particular div
tag only you are seeing the output
called hello world here
and now
let's render the element in the
console.log
in javascript the output statement is
console.log
so it shows the value of this particular
variable
inside the browser console here
so have a look at the console
so that particular div tag is
represented as a react element
and if you can expand the same
so this is your actual react element
and
it has a property called a type
and its value is due
that means this particular div tag is
represented as a react element
that is why the type equal to do
and also it has other properties such as
props
and children equal to hello world as the
text
so this particular text is being
displayed
inside the actual element
and this react element is the part of
virtual dom which i have explained in
the previous lecture
so overall a big application is the
composition of various components and
each component is represented as a react
element
which will be rendered on the dom
whenever the state of the react dom has
been changed
automatically a new react element will
be created in memory
and then react automatically compares
the new object and old object of react
elements
it identifies the changes between the
new react element and older react
element
and then go to the actual browser dom
and update the actual browser dom
with only the specific changes that you
really make
for example if you update the inner html
of the particular h1 tag
only that specific h1 tag will be
updated
rather than re-entering the complete
page
this makes react execute faster
but this example is pretty simple
but in the real world applications we
will not write actual content just like
this element
we will need to create the components as
the classes inside the jsx files
we will learn to create the components
in jsx files in the next lecture
before creating our own components
let us add bootstrap in this application
so that you can make the ui look better
bootstrap is one of the css libraries
that provides plenty of predefined css
classes
to make the ui look professional with
minimal less amount of code
in case if you are not aware of
bootstrap please check out my other
quotes of bootstrap
which covers all essential concepts of
bootstrap from the scratch
in this course we are straight away
using boards tab from the beginning
so that you can see the designs of real
web pages from the beginning itself
so as of now let me remove this
console.log
and i am writing the code in the
index.js
file so here
we have to install essential packages
that are required for bootstrap
actually bootstrap works based on jquery
and popper.js
so you need to install three packages
from npm
that is jquery popper.js and bootstrap
to do so go to your command line window
and make sure you are locating the
correct application folder that is c
current react my first app
and run the command called npm install
jquery
because jquery is the prerequisite for
bootstrap
in other words
bootstrap works based on jquery
internally
and also add iphone iphone save
that means that
we are trying to save this package name
called jquery in the package.json file
of our application
which tells that our application depends
on jquery package
so the command will be npm space install
space
jquery space
hyphen iphone sale
let me run this
after installing the package
you proceed to the next package that is
npm install
popper.js space iphone iphone sale
actually this popper.js package is
optional but sometimes you will be using
accordions or drop down menus
there exactly you require proper.js file
internally
because the code of the bootstrap
internally works based on proper.js
package
so that is why
it is recommended to import popper.js
from the beginning itself
now we are installing the actual package
called bootstrap
so the command will be npm install
bootstrap
hyphen iphone save
once you run this command
the bootstrap package gets installed on
your application
all these packages jquery popper.js and
bootstrap packages will be installed
inside the node underscore modules
folder
so as you can see if we scroll down the
node underscore modules folder
you can see the package called bootstrap
and also other packages such as jquery
and popper.js
now you need to install essential css
files and js files into the index.js
file of your application
so at the top of index.js file
add this code that is
import
jquery
so we are importing jquery.js file from
the jquery package which we have
installed before a moment
and after that
you need to import something called
bootstrap file from bootstrap package
so in the bootstrap folder
there is something called list
means distributable
and inside which we have js folder
in which we have the file called
bootstrap.js file
so we are importing that particular
bootstrap.js file into our application
now
so as of this case we have imported the
jquery and the bootstrap.js file
and just before importing bootstrap
let us import popper.js file also
so import
popper.js slash dist slash
umd slash
popper
and in the command prompt window make
sure you are giving npm start command in
order to execute your application
so now our application executes
including the liabilities of jquery
popper and bootstrap js files
but visually there will be no much
difference
because we have to import one more file
called
bootstrap.css file
from the bootstrap package
so import
bootstrap slash this slash
css
bootstrap.css
this case we are importing bootstrap.css
file into our application
so that
we are able to experience
some visual changes that means the font
has been changed
and also the margin and body of the body
tag has been removed by bootstrap css
file
so these are the four lines that you
have to keep inside your index.js file
in order to import bootstrap and to make
it fully work
in order to actually test whether the
bootstrap is working properly
instead of writing a simple div tag
let me write something called as button
tag
with a class called
btn
and space
beaten hyphen danger
here the btn and btn danger or the
predefined css classes
comes from the bootstrap.css file
so as you can see bootstrap works
correctly that means
gives a red color when you mention the
class name btn danger
so from now onwards you are eligible to
use any bootstrap component in your page
for more information about bootstrap
components you can visit
getboardstep.com site
and then go to documentation
and there go to components and layout
you can see plenty of components of
bootstrap
such as forms buttons
cards etc
in case if you wish to build a real
application based on bootstrap
you can check out my other codes called
bootstrap in two hours
let's come back to the react app
and in the next lecture we are going to
create actual component by using jsx
file
now let us actually learn to create
components by using jsx files
the benefit of jsx file is that
we can use the javascript along with xml
here html tags are written as xml tags
that means they work based on xml rules
such as
all the tags are case in store
and each tag must be closed
or they must be self closed
this is an example of jsx expression
so here in case if you write a different
case for example t capital
this is not allowed because of jsx
and also in case if you forget to close
a particular tag
it will be an error as per jsx
these rules are imposed by xml language
so that is why we call them as jsx
so let me create another file in the src
folder
so right click on src folder
and set new file
specify the file name as app.jsx
and press enter key
now i am writing the code inside the
app.jsx file
here it is recommended to create every
component as a class
for example i am trying to create a
class called navbar
here the navbar is a class in javascript
and i need to export the same
so that this particular class can be
accessible from other classes
so how will you access this particular
class from other files
now come back to index.js file
here
i am trying to add import
a class called navbar
from the file called
app.jsx
so this is how you can export the
component class from the jsx file
and access the same in other file that
is index.js file
make sure you're adding dot slash
to represent current working folder that
is src folder
that is the folder where our index.js
file is present
so dot slash refers to current working
folder by default
but still the output is not changed
because
we are actually rendering the button
element still
so how do you render this particular
content
from the jsx file
in order to convert this particular
class as a component
let me extend a predefined class called
component
here the extends keyword refers to
inheritance in javascript
which tells that this particular child
class
extends the super class called component
which is also called as parent class
you can really import this particular
component class from
the react module
and sometimes you will be writing the
braces
while importing
sometimes you should not
so what makes the difference between
with braces and without braces
for example
if you wish to import react
we have to try writing react
without curly braces
in case if that particular object was
exported with default keyword
as export default
in that case you should not use braces
while importing the same in other file
so since in the react module they have
already exported this particular react
object with export default
you should not write braces while
importing the same
because from one module only one object
can be exported with default
and other objects can be exported with
name
so since this component class was
exported without export default it is
exported by its name
you should write braces while importing
the same here
so what i am trying to say is that
the react was exported with export
default
and the component was exported
with just export keyword
instead of export default
from one module only one export default
is allowed
for remaining objects or classes we
cannot use export default
so that is why we have to import the
same with braces
which are not export default
and this extends keyword says that the
component class is the parent class
and now bar is the child class for the
same
here since the navbar class is the user
defined class you can give any name
instead
for example you might be creating
sidebar or page content or grid or
whatever you wish you can give
and inside this particular class
we are writing a method called render
method
and whenever this component is rendered
automatically react calls this render
method
that is why it's a fixed name
and in this render you can return
anything
but we are trying to return
h1
with hello
but still we cannot see that heading in
the output
it's because we have created the
component but we have not rendered the
same
so how will you render this particular
component
now come back to index.js file
instead of rendering the button you need
to render the nav bar component which
was created before a movement
so let me delete this particular element
and instead i am trying to invoke the
component called navbar component
and as per the syntax of jsx every tag
must be self-closing or
should be closed explicitly
so you have two choices either you can
write the closing tag separately
or you can make it self-closing here
generally self-closing tags are used for
components
now instead of seeing the button you can
see the output from the nav bar
that means by using the method called
render method in the react dom
we are rendering the output of the nav
bar component
and how does that react executes navbar
component
and it automatically calls the render
method for the same
and whichever html tag that you have
written here
that will be rendered within this
specified element
that means
it will find the element called new id
called root which is already present in
the index.html file
so in between the opening and closing of
this particular div tag the actual h1
will be rendered
and in this case
the object of the navbar class which is
automatically created is called as react
element
which is the part of virtual dom
as of now the virtual dom contains only
one object
at the root level
as long as you nest multiple components
the hierarchy will be extended with
parent and corresponding children
for example if you can render another
component inside this particular navbar
component
that will be the child of this
particular navbar component
and you can render multiple child
components right
so in that case the nav bar will be the
topmost root level
inside which we have multiple chain
components
it forms a hierarchy
so that hierarchy is called as virtual
dom
you can investigate the actual output of
the browser
so right click on hello world
inspect element
and i'm using firefox browser you can
try using firefox or chrome or ms edge
at your practice time
so right click on hello and say inspect
element or just inspect
otherwise go to menu web developer
and click on the option called toggle
tools
and in this case you can see the output
called hello inside the root element
this particular root tag was already
created in the index.html file but we
have rendered hello from the navbar
component
but here the noticeable point is that
you can actually return only one element
from this return statement
if you try to return multiple html tags
for example i am trying to written a
paragraph
it is not allowed by default by jsx
it's because internally this particular
jsx syntax will be converted into
regular javascript
by using bevel
which is the javascript compiler
and that particular bevel don't know how
to compile multiple tags at the same
time
for example if you add h1 tag along with
this particular paragraph
it is not valid as for jsx
so babel cannot convert these tags at a
time you can convert either of these
tags only at a time
but
there is a solution for this problem
you can actually nest both of these tags
inside another container
for example a new tag
so as per the syntax of jsx
we have written only one tag called due
and which contains two chain tags and
that is allowed
in this case first it generates a
statement called react dot create
element of due
which is the actual element that you are
trying to
render
and inside which we have two children
that is h1
as well as the p tag
here the content of the h1 is heading
and the content of the p tag is high
you can use the same exact technique
while your component render method
so come back to your code
i am trying to nest a tag called duo
inside which we have something called h1
and p
to make the code readable and
understandable better let me write
multiple lines
so that we can read the code easily
now you can see the heading as well as
paragraph output in the page
so the syntax which we are using is jsx
bevel converts this particular jsx into
js
file and automatically it has added
parenthesis in the return statement
so that either you can write this
particular div tag in the same line
or you can shift it to next line as well
so as you can see inside the root tag
we have something called new
this is the div which we have created
here
and after that
inside that particular div
we have the h1 and p tags that we have
created
so overall this particular content is
rendered by the navbar component that we
have created here
and that is represented as a react
element
but here you can notice a small problem
that is you must always have an extra
div tag along with your content
if you don't require or don't want that
you can use something called
react.fragmenttag
that is react.fragment
the meaning of the react.fragment is
that
without rendering any html tag in the
dom
it acts as a container for both of these
tags
so it satisfies the rule of jsx
that must contain only single tag
at the same time this fragment tag
doesn't render any html code in the
output
it actually renders only the content
inside it
now
inside the root team tag
we can see the actual inner tags
without an extra div tag
so it is up to you finally
if you don't want an extra due tag it is
better to use react.fragment
this acts as a parent or container for
multiple html tags without rendering an
extra due tag
and moreover in this class also you can
use something called export default
so remove this particular export keyword
here
and you can write export default
and specify the class name that is
navbar
alternatively you can write the same
within the class itself
that is as export default directly here
near the class keyword
but don't try to use both at a time
you can use either of the syntaxes
either below or
along with the class name itself
in this example i am writing export
default below the class
so in this case
since the navbar is default export
while importing the same in the index.js
file
you should not use braces
but directly mention the class name as
nav bar
but you can see the same output
in the next lecture let us add a little
bit of css styles for the same
let us try to add css files for this
application
in order to do so
open your explorer window
and then right click on the src folder
create a new file
file name is
index.css
of course you can give any name for
example app.css or anything
and we are using this particular css
file as a global css file
that contains the global css styles
that are applicable for all the
components
so by default any css code that you
write here should be affected the entire
page
not for a specific component
for example i am trying to add
a class called
highlight
and adding some background color
so this particular class can be used
in all over the page in any component
so how will you import this particular
file into the application
so come back to the index.js file
here just like you import bootstrap.css
file earlier
you try to import
index.css file
see since the index.css file is the
local file within the same src folder
you have to prefix it with dot slash
here dot slash represents current
working folder that is src folder
in which we are writing the code
currently
now the css file has been imported in
the application
and it can be used anywhere in any
component
now come back to the same component that
is navbar which is inside the app.jsx
and then for either of the heading or
paragraph you can try to add something
called as
class equal to
and then specify the class name that we
have created here
that is highlight
now you can see that the class gets
updated
like this apart from using predefined
bootstrap css styles
you can also use your own css code in
this index.css file
this is how to add global css file for
your application
in the similar way you can try to create
specific css file for the specific
component
and import that particular css file in
the respective jsx file
that means we can import that particular
css file in the desired jsx file in
which component you required that
particular style
this is how to add the css styles for
your application
in this lecture let us actually use the
bootstrap navbar in this application
it's pretty easy
first open getbootstrap.com site
which is the official website of
bootstrap
then open documentation
from the menu
select components
and then switch to navbar
and it shows the example of navbar in
boards tab
so this is the bootstrap navbar
which can contain one or more menu items
and below is the code of the anal bar
let's expand this
and here you can see the copy button
so that all this particular code
whichever is being shown here will be
copied into clipboard
so that you can return back to your
application
and paste to the same
so i am trying to remove this h1 tag and
p tag inside the app.jsx file
and paste all that particular html code
that we have copied from the bootstrap
website
press alt shift df in order to format
the code
and now let us remove the things which
are not required in our application
first of all we have a navigation bar by
using the nav tag in html
and inside which we have navbar brand
which displays the website name or title
for the application
i am trying to change it as my app
so this will be appear
in the output
but currently we are seeing some
compilation errors in jsx
and
this particular button tag displays the
toggle navigation
that means the menu button for opening
and closing of the menu in case of
smaller devices
so keep it as it is
and then scroll down
let's try to add one or two hyperlinks
each hyperlink is represented as li tag
which means list item
and let me delete the first one
let's follow the second one that is now
item
here you can write your link text for
example
home
and hrf is the url
which should be opened when the user
clicks on home
you can repeat the same for all the
remaining items in future
in this case we don't really want this
particular drop door item
let's delete the same
and even this disabled menu item also
not required for us
so let's delete it
and then this form tag is not required
really for us
and that's all so this is the navigation
bar which we have created here
which contains the nav tag
and then navbar blind item
a tabular button
along with one or more menu items inside
the navbar now
and then after that you will close do
close and then nav tag close
make sure all the opening tags are
closed properly
otherwise you will get jsx compilation
errors
so once you save this code
you can see the application nav bar
along with the tabular menu icon
and if the user clicks on the same
it expands the menu items as you create
and it's a table button so that it can
be closed as well
if needed you can try to change the
color of the navigation bar
for example instead of navbar light
we are trying to apply
navbar dark
and bg dark
now this navigation bar is the darker
one
in case if you want to apply a custom
background color for this navigation bar
you can do the same by using your own
css style
so
open the index.css file which is present
in the src folder which we have created
in the previous lecture
and in this index.css file
let's add a class called navbar style
which contains the background color
property
of your own color whatever you desire
for example
i am selecting some kind of grain
and let's apply this particular css
class
inside the app.jsx file
so come back to the app.jsx file
after writing all the css classes
i'm trying to add something called as
navbar style
which is the class name that we have
created before a moment
still you cannot see the actual color
so come back to index.css file again
and add
important
that means this particular property
overrides the default setting of
bootstrap which was already in the black
color
now you can see that everything is in
green color
that is the color what you selected here
and of course make sure you have already
imported index.css file
in the index.js file like this
this is how will you add the navigation
bar for our application
and of course by default bootstrap
navbar is responsive
so if you try to maximize the screen
it converts into regular nav bar
where all the nav links are shown side
by side
without having any menu button on the
top right corner
so this is the look and feel of the
navigation bar on the larger devices
and this is the look and feel of the
navigation bar on the smaller devices
this is how to create bootstrap navbar
in the react application
this is the navigation bar that we have
created in the previous lecture
but if you can notice the browser
console
you are having some errors in the
browser console
we are talking about this particular
error that is invalid dom property
called class
the reason behind this error is that
in javascript already you have a class
keyword
which is used to create a class
so that is the reason in the same file
you cannot reuse the same keyword for
applying the css class
so alternatively you have to use class
name property
for applying the css class
then it will not be confused with the
class keyword in javascript
so that is the reason wherever you are
writing the css class
you always replace with class name
property instead of class
in order to do so you can take the
support of find and replace in visual
studio code
so press ctrl h
and then specify the find as
class
and replace with class name like this
in camel case
so wherever you have a class keyword
you're replacing the same with class
name property
and click on replace all in order to
replace all instances in the current
file
but
unfortunately
the class keyword which is present to
define the class also got renamed
so let's make this adjusted as the class
keyword
that's all now
that error has been fixed
and let me clear out this class name
duplication
right
so as you can notice that error has been
cleared out here
and that class name must be in camel
case
and let's target another error that is
href attribute requires a valid value to
be accessible
it's because simply hash is not allowed
for href in case of react
to fix this error
always use slash hash
instead of simple hash in react
generally we use hash in href attribute
for representation of dummy link
and make it look like url
that begins with slash
so that react will accept that
even in any other place wherever href
equal to hash replace the same with
slash hash
so if you can scroll down
here also once again we have to repeat
the same
so instead of hash
slash hash
now that error has been cleared out here
this is how do you fix the class name
and hre of related errors in react
we have done good enough by creating
navigation bar
but what's next
i would like to place some content below
the navigation bar
but it is not good to place that content
inside the navigation bar component
itself
and i would like to create a new
component called main content
in which i can place some content that
could be appear below the navigation bar
so let us open the explorer window in
visual studio code
and to right click on src
new file
file name is maincontent.jsx
that means we are going to create a
component called main content
and for all the components file
extension will be dot jsx
and there must be another component
called app component
which wraps both main content as well as
navigation bar
actually in this file called app.jsx
we have really created navbar component
but not app component
so let us rename this app.jsx as
navbar.jsx
so right click on app.jsx
rename
and specify the file name as navbar.jsx
now let us create another file called
app.jsx
inside the src folder
so right click on src add new file
then specify app.jsx
so i wish to really render app.jsx
that means app component
in the index file
so let us create a new component called
app component
inside the app.jsx
so in app.jsx
i am trying to define a class called app
component
so the class name is app
that extends a predefined class called
component
that is imported from react module
and also import react
from the same module called react
because this class will be converted
into react dot
component
so after compilation of the class
it requires a predefined object called
react from this particular react module
and every component must have a method
called render method
that renders something
for example renders a htable tag
so this particular html tag will be
rendered in the webpage as you can see
open the index.js file
and instead of rendering navbar
let us render app component
so i am trying to import app component
from the app file that is app.jsx file
and i'm trying to render app component
but not navbar component
and then
switch back to app.jsx file
here i would like to render two
components that is navbar component and
the main content component
first let me render navbar component
so how can i render one component in
another component
this is called as nested component
so right from the app component
we have to import the navbar component
from the navbar.js
file
notice this navbar is already having
default export
as you can see like this
so that is the reason you can import
this navbar from app.jsx file
so import navbar
from
navbar.jsx file
here dot jsx file extension will be
taken automatically
and to represent current working folder
that is src folder
we have to give
dot slash
and since the navbar component class is
the default export here
known as using braces while importing
the same here
so this is the code for importing the
nav bar from the navbar.jsx file
you can use the same syntax for
importing any component in any other
file
so instead of rendering hello
i would like to render navbar
by writing the opening and closing tag
for navbar
this is the actual class name which we
have defined in the navbar.jsx
file
so always we use the class name of the
component as the name of the tag here
but
you can also write the same tag as
unpaired tag
that means self-closing tag instead of
paired tag
so optionally you can convert this as
self closing
by keeping a space and then slash
so in this case
no need of writing the separate closing
tag for navigation bar
so it works in the same way as expected
and after that i would like to create
main content component in the main
content.jsx file
then i would like to render the same in
the app.jsx file
so let's go to the main content.jsx file
let's add a default export class called
main content
and also import react
and component
from react module
every component must extend a predefined
class called component
and also must contain a method called
render
that must return something for example
at least a tag
here i am trying to return hello from
main content
so for time being just it contains hello
misses
but as you can see still main content
was not rendered in this particular page
it's because we have created the main
content component but we have not
invoked it in the app component
but can you return multiple components
at a time like this
now
in order to do so
we have to use react.fragment
that act as a parent for both of these
tags
before than that
let me import main content
from the file called main content dot
jsx
here dot slash is must in the file path
to represent current working folder
so the react dot fragment tag represents
as a parent
for both of these tags
so as you can see
react.fragment is the parent
inside which we have two components that
is
nav bar as well as main content
now above you can see the nav bar
and below the navigation bar you can see
the content from main content component
so now we can say that the app component
is a root level component or
top most component in the hierarchy
inside which we have two chain
components that is called
navbar and the main content components
so this is called component hierarchy
where app component is a root level
component
and it can have one or more child
components inside it
so the component hierarchy decides the
parents and children
depending on where a component is being
invoked
for example
instead of invoking the main component
inside the app component
if you write the same code
inside the navbar component
suppose i just write the main content
component here
now we can say that app component is the
root level component
and it has only one chain component that
is nav bar
and the navbar component has a channel
called main content
so the component hierarchy changes
depending on which component is invoked
in which other component
all right let me undo the changes
i wish to really invoke main content
only in the app component like this
so this is how you nest the components
and build up the component hierarchy in
react
in the next section
we will render a lot of things
dynamically into these components
we are going to understand about
straight props in the further lectures
so keep continued
but to be frank this is not enough for
building real world react applications
you will really require to know the
functional components
and also advanced concepts such as redax
and that is where you will check out my
full course on udemy
that is complete react ultimate guide
in this course we are going to build the
full pledged e-commerce application
along with red x
redex toolkit router and bootstrap
in this udemy course we are going to
learn the complete react with class
components as well as functional
components
for example if you can check this
section of course project with hooks
here we are going to learn various hooks
such as use state use effect
validations
use callback
and many more advanced features of react
hooks
and importantly context api
and additionally in this course we are
going to learn red x react redux redux
thunk red x promise redux saga
and many more latest features
and moreover in order to properly
understand all these concepts of react
and red x
one should have the proper knowledge on
javascript concepts
especially functions and objects
so in this udemy course we have provided
the prerequisites of javascript that is
javascript functions and objects
and also ecmascript 2015 classes
so even though you have less or basic
knowledge on javascript
you need not worry
in this udemy course we have covered all
the basic concepts of javascript that
are necessary to understand this react
android x
and this is the advanced version of
e-commerce application that we are going
to build in the udemy course
see after entering the essential email
and password
we have the dashboard page
where the user can see his previous
orders
and the products in the cart
from there he can buy the product or
delete the item in the cart
and if you click on the store page
you can see all the available products
you can filter out them
the products and brands which you don't
want
you can select a particular product and
add to cart
and the same is visible in the cart
itself
and from there you can either buy or
delete
so this is the application that we are
going to build with react hooks in the
udemy codes
all right we are good enough to nest the
components that is navbar component and
main content component
but in real world applications all the
content will not be static content right
in many places you require to render the
content dynamically
so this section talks about
how do you render the content
dynamically
and how do you update or modify the
state of the page
in order to store the dynamic content of
your component
you require to create a property called
state inside your component class
so the state is the property that
contains dynamic content of your
component
which you want to render on the page
or it may contain the information that
you want to read from the user as well
so inside your component class that is
main content component
let me add a property called straight
so this property contains the dynamic
information that you want to render on
your component
so this is the object literal in
javascript
which can contain properties
and the property values can be of any
type
it can be number string
date
or even aries also
you can use nested objects inside the
state
for example i would like to display the
title of the page
inside the main content component
so actually i can render something
called h1
or h4
as title of the page that is customers
but this is static information isn't it
how do you make the same as dynamic
you should store this information inside
the state
for example there is a property called
add title
that is equal to customers
and then you can render this particular
property value in this place
so how do you render the value of the
property from the state
open the braces and close the braces
in between opening and closing the
braces you write something called this
dot stage
that means you are accessing the state
property of the current working class
here
this keyword represents the current
working object of the
current class
and inside the state property we have
another nested property called app title
and you can render the same
so now you are getting the same
information that is title
dynamically
this is how you render the content
dynamically by using expressions
so this braces are called expressions in
react
which is used to render the content
dynamically
and the beauty of the state property is
that
as soon as you update the state property
by using set state method
automatically in this place the state
will be refreshed
so when you make any changes in the
virtual dom
automatically react compares the virtual
dom with actual browser dom
and
updates the properties which are exactly
modified
instead of re-rendering the complete
page
for example if you modify this
particular app title property
only that particular property value gets
updated in the dom
rather than re-rendering the complete
page
that's what make react faster
anyways we will see how to update the
state dynamically in the further
lectures
so for time being when you make any
changes in the property value for
example employees
since the page refreshes because of
development server you can see the same
information dynamically render in the
expression
and just for styling purpose you can add
something called class name
notice i am using class name but not
just class
because in javascript you have a keyword
called class in order to create a class
but for css classes we are required to
use the class name instead
for example i am giving border bottom
and margin one
and also padding one
these are just css classes provided by
boardstrap
in case if you are not aware of
bootstrap
or feeling confusing about bootstrap css
classes you can check out my other codes
called bootstrap or refer to bootstrap
documentation in the getbootstrap.com
site
in my course i am not much deeply
explaining the bootstrap related to css
classes because that's all a different
subject
so in the next lecture we will see
how to handle events in react
well in the further lectures i would
like to show the customers grid
so the app title is customers
and it is not the app title and it is
the page title so let me change it as
page title
and render the same as base title
and then i would like to show the
customers count
so let's have a property called
customerscount
and for example it is 5
and in order to render the same i am
just writing
a span tag
so inside the span tag i would like to
render the value of customers count
dynamically
by using react expression
so react expression is the braces
and you can access the state
that is this dot state dot
the property name that is customers
count
that is 5
in order to stride it up
i am trying to add the css class name
that is badge
and badge as
secondary
and let's apply some margin for the same
by writing m2
so every time when you modify the value
of this property
automatically the same gets reflected in
this place
where we render the particular component
property
now we are going to learn how to handle
events in react
in javascript we have events such as
click double click focus blur key press
key up etc
you can handle almost all types of
events by using react
in order to do so we have to write on
click on focus on blur etc attributes
within the specific html tag in react
and there you can call a method that is
written inside the same component
you cannot call the methods of another
component inside this present component
for example let me add a button inside
the h4
by using button tag
so there is a button called
refresh
when the user clicks on this particular
refresh button
i would like to call a method
to do so i'm just writing on click
in camel case
that means on in lowercase
click
c is capital in click
here i can call any method that is
present within the same component
first let me create a method
inside the same component class
so as of now here this is the closing
brace of the render method
after that let me add a method
preferably the method name could be a
meaningful name for example on refresh
click
you can actually give any method name
but better to follow the naming
convention so that your code will be
self explanative
and any developer can understand that
this method executes on clicking the
refresh button
and also let me add comment
to make it easy to understand later
so inside this particular method i can
write any code
that is for example
i am writing console.log of
refresh click claim
you can actually write any code whatever
you require
now i would like to call this particular
method
inside the on click event
so let's come back to
render method
and inside the on click
i am just writing on click
the method name must not be in codes
but must be inside an expression that is
braces
so this indicates that
when the user clicks on this particular
button
we have to call the onrefreshclick
method
notice we should not use the parentheses
for calling
but it must be as it is just name of the
method
and also we have to represent the method
along with this keyword
so we should write this dot method name
in order to access the method of the
current working class object
that is just like how you call this dot
state in the same way you should write
this dot method name
so as you can see when you click on the
button
you can see refresh clicked in the
browser console
but how do you really update the
component state
that's what we will do in the next
lecture
all right in order to update the state
of the page
we have to use setstate method but it
should not overwrite the values of the
state property directly
it's because every time when you update
the state
internally based on the virtual dom the
real browser dom should be updated by
react
so if you overwrite the values of the
state properties
react cannot identify that and cannot
re-render the same ui
so that is the reason you have to use
the set state method in order to let
react update the browser dom
based on the changes made in the virtual
dom
so inside the method called on refresh
click we are just writing this dot set
state
in this case it is a predefined method
and you can supply only the property
values which you want to really update
so we have two properties i don't want
to update page title
but i wish to update only the customer
count
for example i wish to make it as 7
so to do so
just add customer's count property only
and give the updated value that is 7
it will overwrite the previous value
that is 5
and then this particular change will be
taken into virtual dom first
and then react compares the virtual dom
changes
with actual browser dom
and updates the browser dom only for
that specific property will not render
the full ui
so let's click on refresh button
and as you can see it is showing an
error saying that cannot read property
called set state of undefined
the reason behind it in javascript
by default that this keyword context
will be changed
when it is indirectly called
so in this example we are not calling
this method directly
but we are calling the same with on
click event of the button right
so that is the reason
that this keyword by default refers to
button
rather than representing current object
of the component class
in order to overcome this particular
problem
we can convert this method as a error
function
so that that this keyword of the error
function always refers to component
class
rather than a button
so how do you convert this method as a
error function
just
say equal to
and then after the parenthesis
you just add something called arrow
operator
that is equal to and greater than
and that's it you have successfully
converted your method as a error
function so that the benefit of error
function is that
always it's this keyword stick to the
component class
that this keyword context will not
change to any button or something else
so even though you are calling that add
a function through a button that this
keyword refers to a component
try clicking on the button once again
see
as soon as you update the value of the
state
the particular ui gets changed
it's because we are using set state
method in order to update the state of
the component
and
go to elements
right click on the title
inspect element
and try clicking the button again
so as soon as you click on the button as
you can see
only the value of span tag is being
updated
rather than re-entering the complete h4
that is what the actual benefit of using
virtual dom in
react so overall we have understood how
to update the state of the component by
using setstate method
you can apply the same logic for
updating any type of value
not only number
but also for string array or any other
type
in the next lecture i would like to
demonstrate a customer's grid
in this main content component i would
like to show you
how do you render the table that is grid
by using map method of javascript array
first you require to store the data in
the form of array inside the state of
the main component
in order to do so let's write the
properties line bearing
and add another property called
customers
it is an array
so in this array i would like to add all
the list of customers that i would like
to render
inside the customer's grid
whereas each customer is represented as
an object literal
suppose for each customer we have id
name and phone number
similarly let us add some sort of
customers
so this is the date of the customers
that i would like to render
so how do you show this particular array
data in this react component
to do so let's look after the h4
so after closing the h4 i am trying to
add a table tag
and in order to apply the bootstrap
style of table let's add a set of css
classes
that is table
and inside the table i would like to add
header row
and i have just added the column headers
that is id
name and phone number
which displays like this in the large
screen
and here i would like to show the actual
list of customers
so let's take up t body
means table body
so inside the t body i would like to
have a tier tag
with some sort of td tags
so this particular tier tag should be
repeated once for one item in the
customer's array
how do you repeat this particular tier
tag for each customer
to do so in javascript arrays we have a
predefined method called
map
the map method of javascript array
receives an error function
and executes that error function for
each element inside the array
so in order to call it
let's take up an expression
and write
this dot
customers.i mean this dot state dot
customers.map
and then we require to pass
an error function
so this particular error function will
be executed
once for one item in the customers array
and each time you will receive the
customer object as an argument
and then you require to return the tr
tag
inside the arrow function
so whatever you return inside this
particular
arrow function
this will be rendered inside the output
so as you can see since there are five
customers in that array five tier tags
have been generated automatically
as you can see here
see in the t body we have five tier tags
automatically got generated
with empty 3d tags
but how can you render the actual
content
in each td tag you can use your
expression
and you can use the parameter called
cast in order to access the current
working customer
the same error function executes once
for each customer right
so for the first time the first customer
object will be passed into the cust
parameter
that means for the first time cussed
parameter equal to this particular
object
and the second time this is the second
object assigns to cost parameter
like this you can access the customer
details by using cust parameter every
time
so you are writing custom dot
id
so as you can see
it is printing customer ids in all the
rows
you can try accessing the name and other
properties
that is
id name and phone properties
so cust.name
customer dot
phone number
so this is how the table appears in
output
but if you look at the browser console
it shows an error saying that
each child in a list should have an
unique key property
it is a mandate of the react
in order to identify the each row of the
table
it requires an unique key
which is also considered as a primary
key
so you should specify the key property
in the tier tag which is being returned
from your error function
based on this specified key
react identifies each row inside the
table
in our customers area which property is
unique
it is id isn't it
so we have to specify that id property
of the customer is the unique key
inside the
map function here
so go to the tier tag
add key
equal to customer dot customer id
that's it
that error gets cleared
and of course you should not use double
quotes for the same
so this error has been cleared out
and you can see the data comfortably
here
sometimes in the array elements you will
have nested properties
for example we have something called
address
and it contains several properties such
as city
straight etc
for example let's add city
as new delhi
and some other values for each other
customers
like this every customer has their own
address
and each address contains other
properties such as cd
how can you render this type of output
inside the grid
you can access the reference variable
that is cursed dot
address dot cd
that means while rendering you can write
like
cust dot address dot siri
this is how you access the nested
properties in case of arrays
let me add a header row for the same
as you can see cities are rendered in
the table
all right by using map method in
javascript arrays
we are good enough to display the grid
in the page but now i would like to
render some content based on the
condition
means if the condition is true i wish to
render one content
if it is false i wish to render another
content
so that is called conditional rendering
so how can you do that
for example
if the phone number is not available for
the customer i would like to show the
text like no phone
to do so
let me remove some phone number for one
or two customers
let's say james and john
don't have a phone number
it is empty value or can be null
so since the value is null
it is rendered as just empty in the
output
rather than empty i would like to show
the text like no phone
that is called conditional rendering
to do
so come back to the table tag in the
main.content.jsx
go to the place where exactly you are
entering the phone
and here check the content before
rendering
if the custard dot phone is equal to
null
in this case you would like to render
something like
no phone
otherwise you have to render the content
called custom.phone itself
this is the simplest way to render the
output conditionally
sorry it is no phone
let us check the output
as you can see if the phone number is
not available for james and john
it is displaying as no phone
instead of empty text
alternatively instead of plain text you
can also render the tags
so remove the codes
and use any tags such as new tag
and place the text inside the new tag
this is what the exact advantage of the
jsx
anywhere you can return a tag just like
a normal value in javascript
this case if the condition is true
this particular tag will be written
so that this will be displayed in the
output
and in this new tag you can add custom
css classes
by using class name
and specify
background color
and also padding for example 2
and the condition can be better as
custod phone
in javascript the values such as null
undefined empty codes and 0 are called
as false
values
so in case of 4 number property contains
any of these values
in that case it is considered as no 4
number
so in all those cases the condition will
be false
so in the else case we should keep this
new tag
that is here
so we are checking this condition
in case if the four number property is
other than the specified values that is
false values
the custod.4 number property will be
rendered
otherwise it returns this particular div
tag
what are the false values
as per javascript null undefined 0
empty codes are called as false values
in all those cases the condition become
false
so you will render this particular due
tag
and also let's add another class called
text center here
so as you can see it shows no phone as
new tag along with the padding
so the syntax of conditional rendering
is simple
first check your condition
if the condition is true
that means if the condition is not null
undefined or 0 or empty codes
in that case this particular true value
will be returned
otherwise this particular false value
gets written
this is how to render the content based
on the condition
for another example
in e-commerce application
suppose if the product is not available
you wish to show the output in one
format
if the product is available you want to
show in another format
suppose if the product is not available
you want to show it in grey color
for that cases we use this conditional
rendering technique
so in case of conditional rendering
sometimes your code will be much more
complex than this
you may need to write much more number
of statements
to render the content conditionally
such as checking more than one condition
in that cases instead of making this
code complex and lengthy
it is recommended to write the same code
in a method
and call that method in this particular
dd tag
let's try the
same let's cut this particular
expression
and scroll down in the main content
component
that is after the method of
onrefreshclick method
let us add a new method
for example get phone to render
so in this method let's paste the same
code as we have written in the 3d tag
previously
and i would like to return this
particular value of the expression
and give a semicolon at the end
now i would like to call this particular
method
in the td tag
so let's call up this particular method
inside the td tag here
so in this expression we are calling the
get phone to render method
whatever that method returns that will
be rendered here
and what are you going to return in this
method
either phone number or new tag as you
can see
if the phone property has any value
that means any of the truthy value
it returns the phone number itself
in case if it is a false value
it returns the due tag
here instead of using conditional
expression like this
you can also use the regular if
statement
if you have a complex code
for example
i am just writing regular if statement
that is if cust.phone
then we are going to written custod
phone value
else
we are going to return the due tag
so for complex code and complex
operations you can use this technique of
writing your expression in a separate
method
and invoking the same in the expression
wherever you is to render the same
that is in the particular tv tag where
you want to show the output
but in the output you can see some error
saying that
cust is not defined
it's because the variable called cust is
a parameter which is available only
inside the boundary of the map method
but not available outside
so that is the reason we have to pass
the cursed parameter as argument to the
get phone to render method
alternatively you can supply only the
phone number property
instead of passing the whole customer
object
so that is the reason in this method
you can receive only the four number
directly
rather than receiving whole the customer
object
actually it is up to the requirement
either you can pass the complete
customer object
where the output depends on various
properties of the customer
or
in case if you want to check only the
phone number of the customer to render
in this case i am just passing only the
customer phone number as argument
and i am receiving the same inside the
method
and checking the same in the actual if
statement
so
i can just use if phone instead of if
custod phone
and now if you can check the output
again
we have another error called get phone
to render is not defined
it's because we have to use the arrow
function syntax in order to call this
method
even though it seems sometimes optional
it is always advisable to use error
function all over the react
so get phone to render is equal to error
operator
and also we have to use the this keyword
while calling the same
so here we are calling the get phone to
render method
and supply the argument
based on that argument
we will return some value here either 4
number or new tag
and this particular returned value will
be rendered in the same place where you
originally call it
this is how it works
let's check the output
now it's working fine
every time you make changes you have to
save the code
then automatically the page gets
refreshed by
react development server
and now let's remove this unnecessary
border
so go to the h4 tag
and i am removing this water bottom
so that that unnecessary water gets
removed
as you can see here
in the similar way optionally you can
render this particular t-body content in
a separate method
rather than writing the same in the
render method
because as long as the application is
improved
the code of the render method is getting
increased right
in order to simplify the code of the
render method
let's move this particular code into a
separate method
so let's cut this expression
and scroll down in the main
content.jsx file
let's add a method called
get customer role
and preferably make it as an arrow
function
and here written the same expression
use the parenthesis rather than
expression here
all right
now we have to call this particular
method inside the table tag
so let's go up
in the t body
in the expression
let us call the get
customer row method
so now the code of the render method is
simplified
the actual logic of tier tag
is being written
in this particular get customer draw
method
in this way you can simplify the code of
the render method so that
the render method becomes readable and
understandable easily
where each piece of the ui is being
written by different different methods
of course this modification doesn't
affect the actual output it remains same
and no errors in the browser console as
well
so how do you render images in react
for example
before the customer name i would like to
show a random image
for each customer
to do so i'm using something called
pixelm.com
which provides random images
so for every customer in the customer's
area
i am adding a property called photo
and specify the url as https
dot photos
slash id
and you can use any id starting from
1000
and specify the size of the image that
you want for example 60 pixels
the same number will be taken for width
and height
alternatively you can specify the width
slash height also
for more information you can visit
pixelm.com site
let's repeat the same syntax for all the
remaining customers
so we have added photo column for each
customer as you can see here
now how will you display these
particular photos inside the grid
so scroll down in the main content.jsx
file
go to the get customer role method which
renders the actual tr tag of the grid
and we are calling this method inside
the table tag as you can see here
now
in the method
just add a td tag off to the id
and in which you will render the photo
that is cust.photo
sorry let's write photo
so in this case it is displaying the
path of the photo that you mentioned
there
to render the actual image we can use
img tag and bind this particular value
into the src attribute of the img tag
so let's do that img src equal to
the custod photo
by using the expression
that is curly braces
so don't use codes
but use the braces to mention the
dynamic value into the attribute
and as per the recommendation for every
image prefer using alt attribute
and specify any content whatever you
wish for example
customer
in case if the specified path of the
image is not found
or not loaded into the browser
it shows customer instead
let us see the image now
as you can see same image appears for
all the customers
but i want different images
now come back to the customers array
again
that is at the top of the file
we will give different ids for each
image
let's say thousand eleven thousand
twelve and so on
in case if you want to know what are the
available images
you can visit this site that is
pixelm dot photos slash images
there you can find id of the image
for example for this image id is
thousand
these are the random images
you can mention any of these ids
in your url
here the credit goes to pixelm.com site
anyways we have mentioned different ids
of the images
and let's refresh the same page
as you can see
we have different images for each
customer
this is how do you render the images by
using
src attribute of the emg tag
you should bind your dynamic value by
using braces in the src attribute
not only a sorcery attribute you can use
the same syntax for any attribute of any
html tag
sometimes you want to render or apply
the css styles dynamically in react
in that case you can assign an object
into the style attribute of the html tag
for example we have a requirement such
that
if the customer name begins with yes
it should be having blue color
background
and if it begins with j it should be
having red color background
to do so
we can use something called style
attribute
and assign an expression into the same
here we can take the property for
example background color
and in case of value
you can take an expression
and check the condition for example
if cust dot
name starts with yes
in that case you want to return the
value called
green
otherwise you want to return the value
called red
and you will close another parenthesis
here
and since this is a property
we are going to use another curly braces
so in this case you are checking the
condition
if the condition is true
you will return green otherwise red for
this background color property
and in the corresponding table
let me add another th tag for photo
column
so we will have four th tags like this
one is for id photo customer name phone
and cd
so this is how do you apply conditional
styles in react
we are checking the condition here
if the condition is true
we will return green otherwise red
for this background color property
so overall in this place either of the
values will be taken at runtime
for example if the condition is true
that means if the name begins with yes
green will be taken here
and this become as a object lateral
and that will be assigned to the element
by using the expression
that is the outer curly braces
this is how it works
so let's check the output
as you can see we have green color for
squat
and otherwise we have red color for
remaining customer names
sometimes you wish to write much more
complex logic like this
let's say you want to set more than one
property of the style
and also if you want to write more than
one condition
for example if the name begins with yes
green color
if the name begins with j another color
if the name begins with k another color
in that case it's better to write this
as a separate property
so let's go to the top of the class
that is inside the main content class
i am trying to add another property
after the state property that is just
above the render method in the main
content.jsx file
customer name style
and in order to define the values for
the style dynamically let me convert the
same as a method rather than a simple
property
and inside the error function
we are receiving a parameter of customer
name
then we will check
if custname begins with s
we will return the style property as
background color
that is green
otherwise in case if the customer name
begins with j
we will return red
otherwise we will return an empty object
which doesn't specify the background
color particularly
so either of these values gets written
when you call this particular method
now let's call this method in the place
where exactly you are rendering the
content
let's scroll down in the same file
instead of writing this clumsy code
simply write
this dot the method name that you write
here
that is customer name style
now the code looks cleaner and
simplified to understand
so whatever you written in this
particular method
that gets applied for the style of the
td tag
and of course since you don't supply the
value for the cust name it is showing an
error saying that
cannot read the property of starts with
of undefined
because you must supply the value for
the cust name from the place where you
are calling
that is cust.name here
so let us check the output
as you can see
in case if it begins with j it is red
color
if it begins with s it is green color
otherwise it is normal
white color
but setting up the css styles
dynamically by using style property
is okay for one or two properties
but not good if you want to reuse the
same css styles for multiple elements
or you want to set multiple css
properties at the same time
for example you want to set background
color font size
border radius etc at a time
in those cases
better to use the css class
rather than setting style attribute
we will really do that in the next
lecture
now let us convert this method into css
class
rather than setting independent
properties of the css style
to do so let's open index.css file
that is present inside the src folder
consider this as a global css file
that is available for all the components
of your application
it's because
we are importing this index.css file in
the index.js file
here
so it becomes global for all the
components
alternatively if you want to import a
separate css file for each component
you can create a separate css file for
each component
and import the same in the respective
component file
anyways now let's switch to index.css
file
and add two classes that is green
highlight
and red highlight
specify some properties as per the
requirement
so these are the two css classes that
are created in the
index.css file
i would like to apply either of these
classes dynamically based on the
condition in the grid
so the same requirement
if the name begins with yes it should be
green highlight
if the name begins with j it should be
red highlight
so how can you do so
let's come back to the main content.jsx
file
so in case if the customer name begins
with yes
we will return the class name as
green highlight
otherwise we will return the class name
that is
red highlight
you can add more than one css class at a
time
with space operation
for example you can use the built-in
bootstrap css classes
let's say i'm using border left
and border right in case of red
like this you can conditionally add
different set of css classes whatever
you wish
and in the else case you will return
nothing that means no specific css class
and now you can call the same method
in respect to place where you are
rendering the customer's grid
so in the same file that is main
content.jsx file at last
instead of binding the value into style
attribute
bind the same to the class name
that means css class
and of course you are calling the same
method already
that's all let's check the output
in case if the name begins with yes
the green highlight class is not applied
correctly let me check again
oops spelling mistake in the index.css
file
it's green highlight
right let's check again
so as you can see
if the customer name begins with yes it
applies the css class called green
highlight
the same can be seen in the browser dom
as well
and in case if it begins with j
it's having red highlight css class as
you can see here
this is how do you apply conditional css
styles by using css classes in react
in real world applications better to use
css classes rather than applying the
style properties directly
while handling events in react such as
click event or focus event or blur event
etc
how can you pass arguments to the caller
function
for example in this application
i would like to create a button near the
photo that is change photo
and once the user clicks there
i would like to access the currently
clicked customer details
inside the function
so how can you pass the current working
customer details as argument to that
click event handler
before than that
really we don't require the styles of
green and red in further examples
let me remove the same
so let's remove this class name equal to
customer name
style so this td tag remains simple
and let me go to the top of the main
content file
and let us remove this customer name
style method which we don't require
and locate the img tag of the customer
photo
inside the same 3d tag let's add a div
tag
with a small button
that is
chain picture
so when the user clicks on this
particular chain picture button
i would like to pass the current working
customer details as argument to the
click event handler
so let's come back to the code
let's make this as a class name
and on click
we are regularly calling a method
observe carefully
here we are not calling the method
directly
but we are passing the reference to the
method in the onclick property
so in that case it will be difficult to
supply arguments to this particular
method
to overcome this particular problem
you can actually use an error function
so that it will be easy for you to call
the particular method instead of passing
its reference
so there you can pass any arguments
whatever you really wish
and then close the brace
for example i am trying to pass the
current working customer details
as a custom parameter which was coming
from the map method
so the current working customer object
is being passed as argument to this
particular method
of course you can call any method
for example the method should be on
chain picture click
this method is as of now not defined
let's define the same below
so after completion of the get customer
row method
below let us add that on chain picture
click method
as error function
and here i can receive the current
working customer details as custom
parameter
which was passed above
so first of all we are reading all
customers from the customer's array by
using map method
the map method itself gives you the
current working customer as cust
parameter
the same is being passed as argument to
this on change picture click method
and from here we are receiving the value
into the
on-chain picture click method definition
here
let's print the same by using
console.log
that is considered log of
cost
let's check here
now if you click on either of these
chain picture button
for any customer
for example i click this particular
button for the fourth customer
the fourth customer object is received
as parameter
and the same is being displayed in the
console
this is how you supply the value
dynamically through the click event
handler
so while handling any event
if you want to supply the argument value
to the target method
you can use this error function
technique
and it's not only for click event but
also for any javascript events
such as on key press
on key up
on change
or any other javascript events that we
have
for almost all javascript events you
have the properties that begins with on
in react
okay let's make it on click again
but sometimes
you used to really pass the index of the
current working customer
so for this requirement
the javascript array map method itself
provides you the second argument that is
index
so the arrow function of the map method
receives two arguments
the first argument represents the object
from the array
and the second argument represents the
index of the corresponding element
for example for the first customer index
will be 0
second customer index will be 1 and so
on
so after declaring the index parameter
here
you can carry forward the same index
parameter to the on chain picture click
method
like this
so first of all your index is being
given by the map method
and the same you carry forward to the
particular method which you mentioned
here
and also let us receive the same here
you can actually do anything based on
the index
such as updating the specific customer
in the customers area
in real world applications
when you want to really perform edit
delete such operations
this technique will be really useful for
you
so let's check again
this time try clicking on any one of
these buttons for example i click on the
change picture button for the second one
so i am receiving two arguments in this
case one is the customer object
which i have clicked
which includes all the properties
including photo
and second argument is the index that
contains index of the currently clicked
customer
which i clicked here
so since i click the second customer its
index is 1.
suppose i would like to update the
status of the photo
to something else
for this case we can actually use the
set state method
because the customer's array is a part
of the state
of the current working component
and the key logic here is that anytime
when you make any changes in the
customer's array through the set state
method
automatically react read enters the
particular element
based on the change that you make
for example
if you make any changes in the photo
property of the specific customer object
that specific img tag src attribute
value gets updated by react dom
let's try this
so this dot set straight
and i wish to update the
area property
and suppose i am passing an empty array
since you supply empty array
and click on the button
see the complete array got removed
it's because you have really updated the
state of the component
it immediately renders by the react
so
instead of overwriting the complete
array
first let me update the photo of the
specific customer
so where customer array equal to
get customers from the state of the
current working component
and in this array
go to the specific index based on the
value that you have received through the
parameter
and update the photo property of the
same
for example i am trying to change the id
as 1 0 4
and then i am trying to give the same as
the customer's array value here
so as soon as you try to supply the
array
because of the set state method
automatically react updates the
particular image in the specific
customer
let's try here
suppose i click on the change picture
button for the third customer this time
automatically as you can see the picture
has been changed for the same
and let's try once again
i click on the chain picture button for
the fifth
customer as you can see the same image
gets updated here
this is how do you update the state of
the array
by using set state method
so always keep in mind such that
the array is the background information
which renders as a table in the output
any element or information that you want
to change here
you can update the same in the
corresponding array in the state
so that react automatically updates the
same in the corresponding table
this is how to make dynamic changes in
the array in react
i have just added some comments in the
same method for your clarity
in this lecture our goal is to create
the shopping cart application
which displays the list of products as
shown here
in this case the shopping cat is the
component
and each product is another component
that means we are nesting the components
here
where shopping cat is the parent
component in which the child component
called product component has been
rendered
that means the shopping cat component is
the parent component
and the product component is the chill
component
which is rendered through the loop
so here each product is an instance of
product component
so let's come back to our application
currently in the main content component
we are displaying customers list
so let us convert the same into
customers component
where we can create another component
called shoppingcat component
that displays list of products
let us rename this main content
component as
customerslist.jsx
and in this customerslist.jsx
the component class name is
customerslist
and we don't want to render it right now
instead i would like to render
shoppingcat component
so let us create a new file in the src
folder
that is shoppingcat.jsx
import essential react and component
and creating the component called
shoppingcat
and i would like to render this
particular shoppingcat component in the
app.jsx file
so switch to app.jsx file
instead of rendering main content
let us render shopping cat
and import shoppingcat class
from
shoppingcat.jsx file
now switch back to shoppingcat.js
file
have a method called render and in this
render method i would like to written a
new tag
with some default content as shopping
cat
now it displays shopping cat in the
output
and i go to public
index.html file
change the title tag as ecommerce
and then go to navbar.jsx file
change the application name as
e-commerce
so as you can see the browser title as
well as the application title has been
changed as e-commerce
now inside the
shoppingcat.jsx file
let's make this as a heading
that is shopping cat
and in this particular new tag i would
like to render a set of products
so first we have to store the list of
products as an array in the state of the
shopping cat component
[Music]
so in the state of the shopping cat
we have a list of products
and each product contains id
product name
price
and quantity
and let me add few more products
so i have added some data in the
products area of the state
in the shopping cat component
i would like to render this list of
products in this new tag but each
product must be represented as another
component called product component
so i would like to render this
particular ui of the product as a
separate component and that component
should be repeated once for each item in
the array
so let us create another component
called product component
right click on src new file
product dot jsx file
in which i would like to create a new
component called product component
so inside the product.jsx file
import react and other default elements
and written something like product
i would like to invoke this particular
product component for each element
inside the shopping cart
so
read the set of elements from the
product's array
and render
product component in this place
so how will you read the elements from
the array
that is through map method right
so this dot state dot
products dot map
and we have an arrow function
this error function will be executed
once for each element in the array
and this is the closing for the arrow
function
this is closing for the map function
and this is the closing for the
expression of react
and this error function receives each
element as an argument
which can be received here as for
example prod
you can give it any name
and in this error function you can
return any instance of product
that means for each element of the array
it produces a new instance of product
component
here your invoking product component
inside the shopping cat component right
since you are invoking one component in
another component
the component which you are invoking is
called as chill component
and where you are invoking that
component is called as parent component
so shopping cat component is the parent
component here
and product component is the child
in the similar way suppose if you switch
back to app.jsx file
in the app component you are invoking
navbar and the shopping cat
so navbar and shoppingcat are the chill
components of app component
again switch back to shoppingcat
component
you are generating one instance of
product component once for each element
in the array
now in the browser you're getting an
error saying that
product is not defined
it's because we have to import product
component from the mentioned file
so import
product
from which file
that is
product.jsx file
so as you can see since we have six
products in the array six times the
product component has been repeated
that means six instances of product
component has been created
but here the big question is that how
will you supply the data from
parent component to child component
here i would like to supply the data
from parent component to jail component
how is that possible
that's what the topic for the next
lecture
in the browser console we are getting an
error saying that
each child in a list should have a
unique key that is
key property
so remember this wherever you're
rendering an element
by using map method in the react
you must be specifying the key
because internally react identifies each
instance of the element by using the key
property
so that is the reason
while rendering product component we
have to specify the key
the key must be the unique value in your
data source
in our example we have id property which
is the unique
it's not necessarily globally unique and
not necessarily a number
it can be even string or guid
or whatever the data type it may be it
must be unique
generally we use the id as a key here
so i am specifying
prodi dot
that means product dot id
now that error has been cleared out in
the console
but the question is that how will you
supply the data to the product component
so that it can show up the same
information
inside the product component
the data is originally available in the
shopping cat component state the same
must be supplied to the product
component
wherever the product component is being
invoked
there exactly we have to supply that
value
for example shopping cat component wants
to supply id of the product to the
product component
so
it can supply the same
as a property here
for example id is equal to prod dot id
you might be wondering why we have to
supply the same id once again because
already we are supplying the same in key
it's because
key is internally used by react and the
developer no longer has access to the
same to print out
that is the reason whichever the data we
have to print or access in feature in
the product component
that must be supplied while invoking the
child component
so here i am supplying id equal to
product dot id
this prod is the variable which we are
receiving through map error function
for the first time the variable prod
represents the first product
and next time prbod represents the
second product
and you can give any name instead of pr
voting
now let us access the same in the
product component
here i am just adding hash
and then followed by actual id
how will you access this particular id
property which is supplied here
all the properties that are supplied
from the parent to channel are by
default stored in the object literal
called props
so every child component
in fact every component contains a
predefined property called props
which refers to an object that contains
all the property values that are
supplied from the parent
with this kind of syntax
in this case it contains only one
property called id
let's display the same that is props dot
id
so as you can see
the id has been displayed here as hash
of course hash is a constant character
or literal character ignore it
but this is the actual id value that is
supplied from the parent to child
so
the parent supplies the information to
the child by using the properties like
this
and all those property values are
accessible in the channel by using props
optionally just for observation you can
print it out
so in the render method i am just
writing console.log of
this.props
as you can see in the console you can
see id
equal to 1
for the first instance
and id equal to 2 for the second
instance
totally we have six instances of the
product component
that's why it is showing up six times
for one component only one props object
exists
and notice carefully in the props object
you will not see key
here key is undefined
you can only access id but not key
whereas key is internally accessible by
react to uniquely identify each instance
of the element
react identifies which element is being
added removed and changed by using key
internally
but
how will you supply multiple values
other than id
for example i would like to supply the
product name
that is prod dot product name
and also price
now
we are supplying three values into the
props
that is ide product name and price
all these values are accessible in the
product component
now switch to product component
let's display all that information in
the product.jsx file
for representation of each product i am
using bootstrap card
if you are not sure about bootstrap card
card is the box or rectangular
representation of information
where you can render something
about a particular person or particular
product or something else
here each product is represented as a
card order to create bootstrap card the
class name must be called
and inside which we must be having
another view tag called
called body
inside the code body you can write your
actual content to show
in this case you are taking another div
tag
with the text muted
that means with gray color
and then print the static character
called hash
that means id
then how will you access the actual
value of the product
that is this dot props dot id
this property name which you are using
here must be same what do you pass from
the shopping cat component
here you are writing id in lower case
you must use the same property name here
while rendering in the product component
so as you can see
each product is represented as a card
and in gray color the id has been
displayed here
and if you can notice
each props object contains three values
now that is id product name and price
so you can access either of these
properties through this dot props
now continue writing the code in the
product component
add heading that is h5
that is along with padding
that means spacing around the content
along with border top
so top lane border
inside which you will display product
name
and how will you access the product name
that is this dot props dot product name
and in about case it must be class name
but not class
so as you can see it displays heading
five
and i would like to have padding only
for top side that is padding top
and on the next line i would like to add
price
dollar as a static character
and then dynamically render
props.price
so the first due tag displays the id
and the name and then price of the same
so this is the card
which displays id
name as well as price
but there is no any distance or gap
between each card
let's apply some margin for the card
so while rendering the card
add m1 or m2 that means margin
so there is some distance between each
card
and by default the cards are displayed
line by line
how will you render the same side by
side
in order to do so
come back to the shopping cart component
while rendering the products
we have a due tag right
so for this new tag apply the class name
called row
that means we are taking up a bootstrap
row
and as per the bootstrap recommendations
apply the class name called container
fluid for the shopping cat
the container fluid manages the default
margins of the page
this is the code of the shopping cart
component
now the size of the card is not
correctly aligned
as you can see it displays all the cards
side by side
now let us switch to product component
that is product.jsx file
so already we have created a row in the
shopping cart component
let us add call lg6
that means on the small or larger
devices it has to occur six columns out
of 12.
and let us paste the content of the card
inside the call lg6
sorry it must be class name
and class name must be camel case for
the card body
so let's check it out
as you can see all the products are
displayed side by side
that means it displays two products in a
row
but when you switch to smaller devices
you can see all the cards displayed line
by line instead of
side by side
it's because we have given call lg 6
instead of call 6
that means it has to take up 6 columns
on the larger or higher devices
but by default it occupies 12 columns on
the smaller devices
so overall the shopping cat component is
the parent component that invokes
product component as a child
and in the chain component called
product component we grab the
information from the parent by using
this.props
this dot props is the built-in property
in the product component
that contains the list of properties
that are supplied from the parent
while invoking the child
so every component contains two things
that is props and straight
so what's the difference
props is the set of values that is
supplied from the parent component while
invoking the child component
see in this case
in the shopping cat component
we are invoking the jail component
called product
so
whatever the properties that are
supplied here
is called as props for the jail
component called product
but state is the own and private to the
same component itself
the state of one component cannot be
accessible from other component
so even the shopping cat component is
the parent and the product component is
the chilled
each component has its own state
and one component cannot access the
state of other
component for example in the child
component called product component
if there is some state value for example
x equal to 100
this value is private and
own information of the same component
cannot be influenced from other
component
that is the difference between straight
and props
and another difference is
props is always be read only but state
can be read and write
so as a developer you cannot change the
value of the props
but you can anytime update the state by
using set state method
for example if you write a statement
such as this dot props dot id equal to
100
and execute the same application
you are getting an error saying that
cannot ascend to read only property
called idea of object
that's because
props always be read only
so that is what i'm trying to say
you cannot modify the value of props
that always comes from the parent
component to channel component
but state can be anytime changed by
using set state method
of course you should not assign the
value of the state property directly
you must use a set state method only
because
every time when you use the set state
method
internally react calls the render method
to reflect the same information into the
browser dom
and in our application
instead of printing the props value
directly in the expressions
you can take up this information into
the state
so that if needed you can modify the
same later
to do so
let's declare the properties in state
that is for example id
get the value of the props
and assign the saving to state dot id
in the same way you can repeat name
equal to that is product name equal to
this dot props dot
product name
and in the same way price
so as you can see the product component
state has three properties that is id
product name and price
let's render the same here instead of
this third props
we are writing this dot state dot id
same with
this.state.productname
and this.price
now this state can be updated within the
same child element
the benefit here is that
if required the jail component can
update the state but it doesn't affect
the parent one
and output remains same
that is id
name as well as price
and let me reduce the padding top as
padding 2
that is pt2
and there is another alternative for the
same
instead of passing loose values from the
parent component to jail component
you can pass the whole product object at
a time
which includes id product name and price
let's try this
let me supply product
instead of individual properties
that is
just directly past the parametric or
product that is prod
in this case the props contains only one
property called product
so props is an object that contains only
one property called product
and that refers to the complete product
object include id product name price
quantity
so as per the props point of view only
one property is there that is product
and it is an object
now let's update the code of the product
component accordingly
switch back to the product component
instead of accessing this dot props dot
id
you should access this dot props dot
product dot id
here the property name product
is supplied
in the parent component
and let's continue the same for
remaining properties
that is this.props.product.productname
and so on
and it's working as expected in the
output
so the props contain a property called
product
which refers to an object which contains
id product name price and quantity
and there is alternative way for the
same
instead of copying each individual value
into the state
you can also have single property called
product in the state
so in the product component
we have only one property in the state
that is product
that refers to directly this dot prompts
that product
so you need not have individual
properties for id name and price
so in this case while rendering
you should write like this dot state dot
product dot id
because
in the state you have only one property
called product
that is equal into product property that
you supply from the parent
and this dot props dot product is
equivalent to product object from the
product array
which contains id product name price and
quantity
you can access the complete object
through this dot state dot product
that is why you are writing this dot
state dot product dot id
and update the same for product name and
price
so there are multiple ways to supply and
receive the information from parent to
child
so overall which is best policy
either supplying individual values or
supplying the whole product object at a
time
see
if you want to supply the complete
object including all the properties
without adding anything to the chain
then this approach will be better
but
if you wish to supply only set of
properties but wants to hide some sort
of properties
in that case
the previous approach would be better
for example the parent wants to supply
only id and product name but don't want
to supply the price and quantity
in that case supplying individual
properties is the better choice
but in our application right now
i don't want to hide any information to
the child
in that case supplying the whole object
at a time like this is the better choice
so overall in the shopping cat component
we are supplying the complete product
object
while invoking the chill
and this property called product is
accessible as this dot property product
and its reference is stored in the state
dot product in the chain component
so this is how it is working as of now
while invoking the chain component the
parent component can supply a set of
html tags
as content to the jail component
see currently we are in the shopping cat
component
and here exactly we are invoking the
child component called product
so
in between the opening and closing tag
of the product
you can actually supply some html tag
and that is called
content for example here i am writing
some html tag such as h1 hello
this is called as content that is
supplied to child
apart from the
so
the parent can supply two types of
information to the child
that is props as well as content
in the previous lectures we are able to
receive the props and print the same in
the respective chain
but
how will you render this particular
content in the child
it is as simple as this dot props dot
children
for example
in the product component
that is inside the
shoppingcat.jsx file
i am trying to render a button
with class name of btn and btn primary
that means blue color
and for example i am trying to add by
now
so i am supplying the button from the
parent to channel
so how will the child render the same
by default it's not rendered in the
channel anywhere
so you cannot see any buy now button by
default in the channel component
but how will you render the same
now switch to the channel component that
is product.jsx
you decide the place where exactly you
wish to render the same
for example
below the price as the
card footer i would like to render the
same
so
after closing the card body
you try to start something called card
footer
inside the card footer i would like to
render that particular button
and that button must be right side so i
am trying to add text right
so inside the card footer
i am trying to enter something called
this dot props dot
children
here children is a predefined property
in props
which represents the content that is
supplied from the parent
before a moment we are supplying the
button from the parent isn't it
so this particular button tag is
represented as
this dot props dot children
in the channel component
let's check it out
as you can see in the folder you can see
something called
buy now
and the same reflects in the this.props
in the console.log as well
so the props has a property called
children
which represents the react element of
the button
so this is the react element
and type equal to button
and of course we also have product
object along with children
this is how a parent component supplies
content to child component
and chill component renders the same
anywhere in the desired place
here the question is
how to handle the events of chill
elements in the parent component
for example in the chain component that
is product component
there is some button
and i would like to handle the click
event of that button in the parent
component called shoppingcat component
so how to do that
first let's create the button
in the card folder
i am taking two boxes that is left side
and right side
with the float left and float right
and in the right side box i am trying to
place the this dot props to children
and that represents the actual buy now
button
and inside the float left
here i would like to add plus and minus
buttons for the quantity
first let me take a span tag
with
badge
and let's render the quantity
that is this.state.product.quantity
and the default value of quantity is by
default 0 as per the array
and this must be class name but not the
class
and after the badge i would like to add
two buttons
as a button group
the first button is for plus
and second button is for minus
and let me remove this text right css
class
all right
so we have two buttons that is a plus
and minus
by clicking on the plus button i would
like to increase this value
and minus for decrementing the quantity
but instead of handling the kick event
of these buttons inside the same
component class that is the jail class
component
i want to handle the click event of
these buttons in the parent component
that is
shoppingcat component
so how to do that
let's switch back to the shopping cart
component
and after completion of the render
method
let's add another method here
that is for example handle increment
equal to an error function
so this particular error function should
be executed when we click on the plus
button over there
and let me add another method called
handle decrement
and this must be executed when we click
on the minus button over there
and i would like to pass these two
methods as props
so
while invoking the chill component that
is product component
let's supply
on increment equal to
this dot handle increment
that means
hl component i am giving you a method
called on increment
so that you can use this method in order
to handle the event in the child
component
in the similar way let me supply handle
decrement
so these methods are available as on
increment and on decrement properties
inside the district props of jail
component
so
let's go to product component that is
the chill component
now you have access to this dot props
dot on increment and on decrement
see in the browser console also
you can check the props
it contains on increment as well as on
decrement
and those are the
functions let's handle the click event
of the buttons
and bind these methods that is on
increment and on decrement respectively
for these two buttons
so
in the product component
for the first button
on click
that is equal to
this dot props dot
on increment
in the same way for the second button
on click equal to
this dot props dot on decrement
notice the name it is not handle
increment and handle decrement but it is
on increment on decrement
the actual method names that is handle
increment and handle decrement is not
the matter here
because
the names that you mentioned here is
considered to be a part of the props
so only these property names must be
used here in the props but not the
actual method names
so
let's add some console.log bases in the
handle increment and handle decrement
inside the shoppingcat component
so this is handle increment
and this is handle decrement
let's check it out
i clear the console
and click on any one of these buttons
as you can see
it calls handle increment method
that is created in the parent component
actually click event was raised in the
channel component
but the corresponding method of the
parent component executes
in the same way if you click on the
minus button you can see the handle
decrement method executes
this is how you handle the click event
of the jail component
in the parent component
that means the events are originally
raised in the child component
and those are handled in the parent
component
but here the question is that
how will you supply the information that
means arguments to the even handler
methods
so in the click event of the jail
component
i would like to supply the arguments to
the parent component method
anytime when you are trying to pass
event arguments you must be using error
function right
so make this as error function
and then you can call the method instead
of mentioning the method name
and then you can supply essential
argument values that you want
for example i would like to supply the
complete product object reference
that is present under this dot state
so i am supplying the argument of this
dot state dot product
to the on increment method
so when the user clicks on this
particular plus button
first of this error function execution
starts
as a part of that
we are calling the on increment method
of the parent
and supplying the current product
information
as argument to that particular method
and let's remove the same in the
respective shopping cat component
now i am inside the shopping cat
component that is a parent component
let me remove the product
and display the same for our information
in the console.log
let's repeat the same for remaining
other method that is handle decrement
so switch to product component
make this click event as error function
and
call the handle decrement method
and then supply this dot state dot
product as argument
means you are supplying the current
product object as argument to the
respective method
and then switch to shopping cat
component
let's receive the same product
and display the same in the console.log
so overall the kick event raises in the
chain component that is product
component
you are calling the method of the parent
and supplying the current product as
argument to the same
so let's execute this
i am clearing the console
and click on plus button for any
component
so i click on plus button here
as you can see it invokes handle
increment
and has reference to the product
that is the product which you click here
in the same way if you click on minus
button for the same
it calls handle decrement
and has referenced of the same product
so you can access the same values that
is id product name price and quantity
and even if you want you can update the
same
let's write
i wish to really update the quantity
value
so by default it is zero
let's either increment or decrement it
based on the button
now switch to the shoppingcat
component.jsx file
how will you update the quantity
if you write like dot quantity equal to
quantity plus 1 it doesn't work really
because
react will not re-enter the information
when you directly assign the value into
a specific property or specific array
check the output
i click on the plus button here
nothing increments
but
internally the property value is being
updated every time
but it doesn't reflect in the real
output
it's because every time when you are
expecting some change in the output
that means expecting some change in the
state
you must use set state method
you should not update the value of any
property directly in the state
how can you do that
first we have to identify the reference
of this product object
in the products array which you got here
in order to do so let's use index of
method of the javascript arrays
before then that let's clone
the products array into a local variable
for example all products equal to
just clone everything of this dot state
dot products
in ecmascript 2015
the spread operator that is three dots
gets all elements from the particular
array
so
all the elements of this particular
array will be copied into a new array
into this particular reference
variable that means we have a clone of
this array into this new variable
so
from this clone
you have to search for
a specific product by using index of
method
index of the product parameter that you
receive from the child component
so this method gives you the actual
index of this specific product
and let's print the same
let's check the output as of now
i clear the browser console
and click on any one plus button here
as you can see it displays the index
that is true
that means we have clicked on the
product at index number two
so we have the index with us
based on the index you can access the
specific element directly from the array
right
that means from this array
we can access the index number 2 that is
samsung
qled tv
so the same array has been cloned into
all products right
so you can access
all products of
index
so overall you are fetching the product
object based on the index
let's check the output as of now
i clear the browser console
and click on the plus button for xbox
as you can see you can access the
product object based on the index
now in this object you have to apply the
quantity value
so
you should write like
all products of index dot quantity
plus plus
because you want to increment the value
and this particular quantity has been
updated in the clone
of the array
but not in the original array
the state still contains the old
information before updating
so how will you update these changes
into the actual state
that should be done only by using set
state method of the component
so this dot set state
and which property wish to update
products
and what is the new information that is
all products
and notice now this all products array
contains the updated quantity which is
incremented here
so the complete array will be
overwritten
in this place of products property
so that react compares the actual value
which is really updated
and
updates the same exactly in the browser
dom
instead of re-render the same
so if you think the complete product
details will be updated in the browser
dom it is wrong
it really compares which value really
updated
only that specific information will be
reflected in the respect to browser dom
so as you can see
switch to elements in the developer
tools
and right click on your plus button and
say inspect
now you are pointing to plus button of
the particular element
and try to click on the plus button
there
as you can see it really updates only
the number two instead of one
i keep clicking the plus button every
time it updates only span so it
highlights only the span tag but not any
other html tag
so that's what react will do it updates
only the specific html tag instead of
re-entering the complete browser dom
anyways here you can see the change in
the quantity
so overall what are you trying to do is
that
first user clicks on the button of the
channel
that is plus button for example
then you are invoking the on increment
method of the parent
and supplying the current product as
argument for the same
now in the shopping cat component that
is parent component
the handle increment method executes
and you receive the product object as
argument which is supplied by the child
then you clone the complete products
array into all products variable
then get the index of the supplied
product argument
example you got the index number two
and
update the value directly in that
quantity property
and overwrite the changes in the state
by using only set state method
this is how you update the state
let's clean up the code that is remove
the console.log statements
now let us repeat the same logic for the
handle decrement method also
here the logic remains same
only the difference is
instead of you write plus plus you are
writing minus minus
so i just copy and pasted the same code
instead of plus plus
i am writing minus minus
so let's re-execute the same
now you can use plus button to increase
the value of the quantity
and you can use minus button for
decreasing the quantity
but there is a small issue here
if you keep clicking minus button
it becomes unlimited
it goes negative value as well
and another issue is that
if you keep clicking plus button there
is no upper limit so it increments up to
unlimited number
suppose you want to keep upper limit for
the quantity increment
suppose
you wish it should be maximum 10
so how will you keep validation that is
minimum 0 and maximum 10
so before increasing or decreasing we
have to check the condition
if the condition is matching that means
if it is between 0 to 10
then only it must be incremented or
decremented respectively
but what if you want to change it in
future
let's say the child wants to supply the
minimum and maximum value
and accordingly the parent should work
so instead of hardcoding the minimum and
maximum values in the parent component
lets chill dynamically supply the same
so
while calling on increment method from
the child component
let's pass the argument value
currently i am writing the code in the
chain component that is product
component
in the click event of the plus button
while calling the on increment method
let's supply some argument value
that is the maximum value for
incrementation
suppose maximum value for example 10
so that in future whatever the maximum
value that child requires it can supply
you can change it later for example 20
or 30.
and in the similar way let's supply
minimum value for decrementation
let it be 0 for example
so
on increment has two arguments that is
the reference of the current product and
max value
and on decrement method has two
arguments one is reference of the
current product
and minimum value for the quantity
let's receive the same in the parent
component that is shopping cat component
so switch to shoppingcat component
here in the arguments you can receive
something called max value
and in the handle decrement you can
receive the min value
in the handle increment method
before incrementation let me check
if the quantity value is
less than the max value
then only we have to increment it and
update the state
otherwise you need not increment and you
need not
set the state
so there is no need of else case
whenever the quantity is less than the
max value
then only the quantity must be
incremented and update the state
similarly let me check the condition in
the handle decrement method also
if the current quantity of the current
product is
greater than the min value
then only we have to decrease the value
and update the state
otherwise nothing need to be done so
there is no else case for the same
now let's check the output
so i click on the plus button it keeps
incrementing up to 10
but after that even though i click on
plus button there is no any change in
this output
because we checked the condition before
real incrementation
and in the same way let's use the minus
button
so 10 becomes 9
and so on
up to 0.
and after 0 it should stop right
but in this case it is working even for
-1
but after that i cannot decrement
anyways let's fix this issue of minus 1
here
unwantedly i have just added equal to
so it should be if quantity is greater
than min value then only it must be
decremented
but not for equal to
let's try again
so i click on minus button
see there is no change in the value
because
the minimum value is 0 here
you can increment
by using plus up to 10
and decrement the value
and in the same way you can try updating
all remaining quantity of all the
products
it works as expected
this is how you handle the events of the
channel by using parent component
now i would like to create delete button
for each product
so if i click on the delete button for
the product that product must be deleted
from the list
in order to do so let's display the into
mark that means delete mark by using
font awesome package
as of now we have not yet imported font
awesome package
so let's install the same first
open the command prompt window and
locate
secure and react my first app
and install the package called font
awesome
that is by using npm install font
awesome hyphen f and seo
font awesome is one of the third party
packages which provides plenty of icons
which can be used in the applications
such as error marks plus symbol
and many more icons
this is the official site of 1000 that
is fontousam.com
here you can search for icons whatever
you wish
for example i am just writing
arrow
you can see plenty of icons of arrow
here
some of the icons are free and some
other or pro version
that means requires payment
anyways let's use the free icons for
timing
and when you install this particular
package
it provides
1000.css file on your node underscore
modules folder
let's import the same
so
i am writing the code in the index.js
file
after importing your bootstrap
import
4000 package
and under css folder
import font thousand dot css file
so now you have successfully integrated
font awesome in your application you are
ready to use any icon from the same
now go to the channel component that is
product component
at the top of the card
that means here i would like to display
the delete button
towards the right
that means i would like to show a delete
button at the top right corner of the
card
so after printing id of the product
let's add a span tag
and that must be present
at the right side so pull right
and use the font also
so by using font awesome you're
displaying the into mark that is fe
hyphen times
so this displays the interval that that
means delete button
at the top right corner of the each
product
let's apply hand symbol that means hand
icon when you hover on the same
so
switch to the css file that is index.css
let's add a custom class that is hand
hyphen icon
with cursor pointer
it is the user defined css class
and already we have imported index.css
file in the index.js file
so straight away we can use that class
in the product.jsx file
so in the span tag here
let's add the class name that is hand
hyphen icon
so that you can see hand icon when you
hover on the same
now when the user clicks this i would
like to execute some method in the
parent component
just like what we have done in case of
press and minus buttons
so go to the parent component that is
shopping cat component
after completion of the handle increment
method
let's add one more method
that is handle delete
and let us receive the product object as
argument
and let's get the index of the product
just like above
based on the index we have to delete the
corresponding product isn't it
so
all products dot supplies
of index comma 1
that means starting from the specified
index
one element will be removed in the all
products array
now we have to reflect the same changes
in the
state dot products
that is done by using set state method
right
so this is the statement for the same
if you think like you want to remove the
element directly in the state dot
products it never happens
you need to clone the array into all
products variable
and you need to remove the element in
the all products
and overwrite the same changes into the
state dot products
that is by using set state method
this is how it works
now let us call this particular method
in the click event
of the child
before than that
the parent has to supply this particular
method reference
while invoking the child here
so while invoking the product component
you need to supply the reference of the
handle delete
as for example on delete
here handle delete is the actual method
name
and on delete is just reference name for
the same which is represented in the
props
you can use the same name in both cases
or you can use different name for
avoiding the confusion
so in the chilled component props
you can see the properties such as on
increment on decrement and on delete
but actual method names are handle
increment handle decrement and handle
delete respectively
and now you can use this property
in the child
component now switch to the channel
component that is product component
near the span tag let's apply the on
click event
so when the user clicks on this delete
button
have an error function
and there you can invoke the
props dot on delete
and supply essential argument of product
that is this dot state dot product
so when the user clicks on this
particular span tag
you are calling on delete method that is
on handle delete method
in the parent component
and supply in the current product as
argument
which will be eventually deleted
in the parent component itself
so let's run this so if you click on the
plus button over here
you can see the same has been deleted
you can click any delete button of all
the products
so whichever the delete button you click
the same is being removed from the
parent component
how does it work
so
first user clicks on the delete button
in the channel component
and you are calling the on delete method
of the parent
and supplying the current product
so in the parent component in the handle
delete method
you are receiving the currently clicked
selected product
and
removing the same element based on the
index in the all products
and overwriting the updated all products
in the state dot products
then react compares the previous state
and this state
and identifies the changes
it identifies that the specific object
has been deleted from the array
and accordingly
it will re-execute the map method
so that the corresponding element will
be removed from the array
this is how when you click on delete
button the corresponding element is
being removed from the dom
but suppose you would like to show a
confirmation dialog box before deleting
how can you do that
so in the handle data method in the
parent component that is shoppingcat
component
let's add something called conform
with message or reshore to delete
that is exactly window.confirm
so if the user clicks on the ok button
then this confirm method returns true
then you are removing the element and
updating the state in the current
component
otherwise you are not deleting anything
so there is no need of any else case
let's re-verify the same
so i click on delete button for the
first one
and it is asking me our show to delete
if i click on ok
then only it removes
but next time i click on cancel
it's not removing anything
it remains same as it is
this is how you delete the elements of
the jail components from the parent
component
react is responsible to render the
components and manage the component at
run time
that means react is responsible to
completely manage the life cycle of the
components
during the execution of the components
react executes some predefined methods
internally at different phases
and those are called as life cycle
phases
totally every react component contains
four phases
that is mounting phase
updating phase
unmounting phase
and error handling phase
at each phase of the component different
methods will be executed
the developer can use those methods
in order to manage the component
and load the information from the server
and also make the component re-render or
avoid re-entering the component
wherever it is not necessary
so it is necessary for the developer to
know what methods will be executed at
which phase
and what kind of code can be written at
each method
mounting phase is the phase
where the instance of the component is
being created and rendered for the first
time into the dom
for example you have a component called
shoppingcat component
when you execute that particular
shopping cat component
the shopping cat component will be
mounted
that means rendered on the browser
during that process the mounting phase
will be executed
as a part of that
three methods will be executed of your
component class
that is constructor
render
component did mount
execute in the same order as they
mentioned
every time when the property value or
state is changed
the updating phase will trigger out
in this case render component did update
will be executed
and at the time of leaving or closing
the application
the unmounting phase will be executed
generally this happens only when the
routing is enabled
and the user navigates to another route
from the current route
or it also executes whenever the parent
component removes the instance of child
component
and finally the error handling phase
will be executed
whenever react identifies an error
during the rendering or life cycle
method
or constructor of the child component
for example we have a shopping cat
component which contains children of
product components
while executing any one of the product
component it has an error
so that leads to error handling phase of
the shopping cat component
or during the render method of the
shopping cart component itself there is
an error
at that moment also error handling phase
of the shopping cat component occurs
in this phase only one method that is
component date cache method executes
if you can check react docs
there are some additional methods that
you can identify
for example get derived state from props
etcetera
but those methods are noted as extremely
rarely user methods by react docs itself
here we are focusing on only the methods
that are really useful and frequently
used in the real world applications
so 90 percent of the times we use these
methods in the real world applications
so how and when we use these respective
methods at different phases
we will understand about each phase by
lecture will lecture in this section
first let me demonstrate mounting phase
to you
as a part of the mounting phase the
constructor render and component did
mount methods will be executed in the
same sequence
the constructor is suitable for
initialization of the state
and binding the event handler methods
but
what you should not do in the
constructor is that
you should not make http requests or
fetch the data from database or
something
in the render method you should not
update any changes to the props or state
that means you should not use set state
or anything like that in the render
method
but the render method should return the
ui
as html element
and the component did mount method
executes
after execution of the constructor
render
and the complete lifecycle of all the
children
let me demonstrate all these three
practically
so we are taking the example of shopping
cat component and the product component
here shopping cat component is the
parent
in which one or more product component
instances are displayed like this
so this is your shopping cart component
and each box
that is each product is an instance of
product component
we have six products in the array so six
instance of product component has been
rendered
so in this context
inside the shopping cat component
and trying to add something called
constructor
by definition the constructor executes
as soon as an object is created for this
particular class
that is the definition of object
oriented programming
in other languages
but
being in react
the constructor will be converted as a
function
so there is no object for this class
actually to be frank
the constructor executes when the
component is mounted that means
execution started
the major thing that you will do with
the constructor is
initialization of the state
in all the previous lectures we are
directly initializing the state property
by assigning an object literal into the
state property
that is one way
the alternative way for the same is that
you can initialize the same state
in the constructor by using this dot
state equal to something
so you can do either of these
either outside the constructor state
equal to object
or in the constructor this dot state
equal to object
and moreover
the constructor is the only one place
where you can directly initialize the
state by writing this third state equal
to
in nowhere else that means in nowhere
other methods you should assign the
values
into the state directly by ascending
that means if you try to assign this dot
state equal something in other methods
such as render it is not valid
in all the methods except constructor
you must use this dot set state in order
to make updates in the state
so if you run this application now
in the browser console we are getting
errors
that is
must call superconstructor in the
databoard class before accessing this or
writtening from their order
constructor which means that you must
call the superclass constructor
inside your derived class constructor
that is shoppingcat componentconstructor
so
you should write like so for
so by this statement you are calling the
superclass constructor
what is the superclass here the
component class
so from this statement you are calling
the super class constructor that is the
constructor of the component class
that is the parent class
now that error is cleared out
and moreover
in this case the problem is that
in case if someone has supplied some
props for this component
that you will miss out
because the super class constructor
expects a parameter called props
that must be supplied from the statement
so how will you receive the props which
are supplied by some other components
while invoking the shoppingcat
component for example
we are invoking the shoppingcat
component from app.jsxfile
so in the app.jsx file suppose you
supply some value such as x equal to 10
so this x value will be received
into the constructor
so in the shopping cat component the
constructor by default receives those
props
and you can initialize the same in your
current working
component
by passing the same to the parent class
constructor
so first you are receiving all the props
that are supplied from your parent
component
that is app component
and you are passing the same to the
parent class constructor
so these properties will be initialized
in the props property of the current
working class
so this is the common code that you will
write in every component
so it's a three-step process
first
the parent component supplies one or
more props
that will be received into the
constructor first
and then you are re-passing the same to
the parent class constructor
those will be initialized in the current
working component then
in that way the props is really
available in your component
so anytime when you're creating the
constructor in your component class
don't forget to call the parent class
constructor by using super
and also supply the props for the same
so what code should not be written in
the constructor is that
you should never make http requests
inside the constructor
the same can be made in the component
did mount method
because that executes after completion
of all the component lifecycle
of all the child components
that are rendered inside the render
method
so as a sequence of execution
first the constructor of your component
executes
and then your render method of your
component executes
as a part of that
in case if you invoke any other chain
components
for example we are invoking some x
widget component
the complete lifecycle of x widget
component executes starting from
constructor render and the component
read mount
and after completion of the lifecycle of
x widget component
and other child components
the component did mount method of your
shopping cart component executes
so let me add it
after the render method i am trying to
add a method called component read mount
so this method executes after the
constructor
and render method of the current working
component
including the lifecycle of all the child
components if any used in the render
method
so this method is a perfect time to make
any http requests to fetch data from
database or any other data source
but as of this lecture we are not making
any http requests to fetch data from
data source
we will do that later in the further
sections
but for a timing let me add console.log
messages for each place
that means in the constructor first
so console.log of
constructor of shopping cache
and i am adding a console.log message in
the render method
and also after that
i am trying to add a console.log message
in the componentdidmount method of the
same component
so let us see the output to identify the
sequence of execution
as you can see
first it has begin with
constructor of the shopping cart
component
then render method of the shopping cat
all the jail components have been
executed
that means the complete lifecycle of
jail components execute here
and after that the component did mount
method of shopping cat component
executes
this is how do you understand the
mounting phase of your lifecycle of
react component
in the next lecture we will demonstrate
updating phase
let's focus on updating phase
whenever the props or state is changed
by the developer the updating phase
executes
the props out supplied from the parent
component and the state is the one of
the same component itself
so whenever either of these props or
state has been changed at runtime the
updating phase will be triggered out
as a part of that
the render and component did update
methods we will execute in the same
sequence
first the render method executes
which returns a html element and that is
treated as a react element
and that is treated as a virtual dom
then react compares the new virtual dom
with old virtual dom which was already
rendered
and identifies the differences or
changes
if any changes are found
the corresponding changes will be
updated in the browser dom
in this case this render method is the
same which was already written in your
component
but let me add the component did update
method
so inside your shoppingcat component
already we have the constructor
let me minimize it for clarity
and then we have render method
and then we have componentdidmount
method
and after that let me add
component did update method
and let's have a console.log message
and update ue uppercase
let's test it
as you can see first constructor then
render method
and lifecycle of all the children
and after that component date mode
method executes
notice there is no component date update
method executes here
so whenever there is some change in the
props or state
then only the update phase will be
executed right
so for initial render component update
method will not be executed
for example let me click on this plus
button to increase the quantity
so in this case
only it has executed the render method
the lifecycle of all the children
and then the component date update
method executes
let me clear the browser console and try
again
so i click on the plus button
the render method of the shoppingcat
component
lifecycle of all the children
and then component date upgrade method
executes
so
the component date update method
indicates that
all the children have been loaded
successfully in the current working
component
and in this component rewrite method
you have two automatic arguments that is
pre props
and prime state
that indicates previous properties and
previous state
and already we have the current
properties and current state
if needed you can check it out
that is this turnpops
and this third state
so totally i am printing four values
through this console.log
one is the message that is component
read update
previous props previous state that are
received as automatic parameters
that are supplied by react automatically
and also the current working props and
state of the current working component
that is shopping cat component itself
so let's run this
of course for initial render component
did update method will not execute right
so let me clear the browser console
and click on the plus button for any one
component
for example it supplies
so as a result
the shoppingcat component went to update
phase because
there is some change in the props
that means the products array have been
updated by the parent component
so in this case the render method
executes
and the lifecycle of all the shell
components execute
we have six components that's why it
shows this
six times
and then
only one time component did update
executes for the shopping cart component
and this is the previous props
and this is the previous trade
and this is your
this dot props
that means the current props
and this is the current state
and what has been really changed is that
if you can verify there is no difference
between the previous props and the
current props
both are x equal to 10
but
there is some change in the state
so in this in the first case
you can notice the products with
all quantity as 0 0 for all the products
and in the current state
expand
you can see the quantity has been
changed as one for samsung queue led tv
so
this is how you identify the changes or
differences between the previous props
and current props or
previous state to current state
sometimes you will have a logic
that is
whenever there is some change in the
particular property or particular
element
in the state or props
you want to make http request to fetch
additional data from the server
or
make any other changes in the database
so
in that case you are free to perform any
kind of database operations by making
http requests
in the component did update method
but always make sure you make http calls
conditionally but not unconditionally in
this method
that means we have to check
for example if previous props dot
x equal to
current props x value
then
i don't want to make any http call
if it is not equal to the x value then i
would like to make http call
so i should make http call only when
this condition is true but not
unconditionally
in case if i make http call
unconditionally without checking any
condition
it leads to performance issue because
this method will be executed for each
change in the state or crops
in a real-world application
the state will be updated many times
from various buttons or various clicks
of the user
for example your real world application
may consist of various buttons such as
filtering sorting
delete new etc
for each button click the state may be
updated
and each time the state is updated
the component goes to updating phase
and for each time this component did
update method executes right
so if you make http call unconditionally
for each updating phase a http request
will be sent to the server
so
it will be a performance issue
so that is the reason
it is not advisable to
make http calls unconditionally in this
method
but
if you have a proper reason or logic
you can check your condition if the
specific condition is true for example
if the user has entered this particular
input value
then only you will make http call in
this component read update method
otherwise it is better to avoid such
http call if you don't require so
so anyways currently as per our
application we don't require an http
call in this
case so this is how do you understand
the updating phase of the lifecycle of
the component
now let's focus on unmounting phase
in this phase mainly one method will be
executed that is
component will unmount
this phase will be occurred
before leaving or deleting the current
instance of the component
generally this occurs when the user
navigates to another route in case if
routing is enabled
or when the parent component deletes the
current instance of the current working
child component
so in either of these cases the
component will amount will be executed
and you will use this component will
amount method in order to unsubscribe
that means cancel the http requests if
any
so overall you will place your cleanup
code to cancel the http requests in this
method
let me demonstrate this
so presently this condition is not
required for us let me comment this out
and let me add the message called
componented update for shopping catch
that is in the component update method
so this particular component will
unmount method will execute
before deleting the current instance of
the component that is shoppingcat
component
in this method let me add console.log
message
component will amount
for shopping cat
so let's run this
when the page is refreshed
that is called mounting phase
in that case the constructor
render
the channel component lifecycle
and component did mod method execute
after that
whenever some state of props has been
changed for example i click on plus
button
the render method
the lifecycle of all the child
components
and then component data update methods
execute
after that
when the user navigates to another route
for example if the routing is enabled
the user clicks on another hyperlink in
the navigation bar
in that case component will unmount
method will be executed for the shopping
cart
but as of this stage we have not enabled
routing in this application right
so that is the reason it doesn't trigger
component will unmount method
but let me demonstrate the same for
product component
so let's copy the same method into
product component
so in the product component
after the render method i am pasting the
same
and let me make this as
component will amount for product
and let's run this
and let's clear the browser console
now let's delete any one child component
instance
for example i click on close button or
delete button for the sony camera
and i say yes
as you can see the component will
unmount method has been executed for the
product component
because that specific instance of the
product component has been
cleared out
and after that update phase has been
executed for the shopping cat component
so it doesn't trigger component will
unmount method of the shoppingcat
component
it executes only when the routing has
been changed
or
the component has been removed by the
parent that is app.jsx file
this is how do you understand unmounting
phase
what kind of code will you write in this
component will unmount method
you can write some cleanup code
to cancel http requests if any
this is how you understand
unmount phase in the component life
cycle
in case of nested components
how does react manages the lifecycle of
parent and child components
that means will it perform the complete
lifecycle of parent component first and
then child component next
or
first child component and then parent
component
actually you are rendering the child
components through render method of the
parent component right
so every time the render method is
invoked the chill components lifecycle
will be performed
and after that it returns back to the
parent component life cycle
to understand this process clearly let
me demonstrate the life cycle of
the parent component that is shopping
cat component
and the chill component that is product
component
so let's back to the code
in the shopping cart component
let me comment out all these products
let's make it single product to avoid
the confusion
so we have only one product that is
iphone and
we have considered log messages in all
over all the methods that is in the
constructor of the shopping cat
and the render method of the shopping
cart component
and also in the component date mount
method of the shopping cart component
and the component did update method of
the shopping cart component
and component will unmount method of the
shopping cart component
and these are even handler methods
we are not focusing on them
and now switching to product component
let me add those lifecycle methods in
the product component too
so
in the product component let's add the
constructor
and the constructor receives the props
as argument
which are supplied by the parent
component
and you must re-pass the same to the
parent class that is
the component-based class
by using super keyword
so this will reset or overwrite the
props
of the current working component
and after that you can set the state
by writing this dot state
so this.state is equal to the state
object that you have written already
and let me add the console.log message
and then another console.log message
inside the render method
and after that
adding component did mount method
and also component will unmount method
all right so these are all the methods
that are added
in the product component
so we have complete lifecycle methods of
parent component that is shoppingcat
component
as well as in the channel component that
is product component
let's test it
so
when you run this application for the
first time
by default it is in the mounting phase
as a part of the mounting phase
it begins with the lifecycle of the
parent component that is a shopping cat
first the constructor of the shopping
cart component
then render method of the shopping cart
and the constructor of the product
render method of the product
component date mod method of the product
so these three lines indicate
the mounting phase of the chain
component
which executes after render method of
the parent component
and after completion of the mounting
phase of the chain component
component did mount method executes for
the parent component
so this is the total mounting phase
includes parent and shield
now when you click on
any state update for example plus or
minus
oops let me clear the browser console
let's click on plus button
now it went to update phase for both
components
first it begins with the update phase of
the parent component
because the data of the parent component
has been changed first
it begins with the render method of the
shopping cart component
as a part of that it calls the update
phase of the
chill component that is product
component
so what methods must be executed for the
jail component update phase that is
render method and component data update
method
so it executes a complete update phase
of the jail component
that includes render and componented
update method of the child component
and after that
it executes the component deduplic
method of the parent component
and now let me clear the browser console
let me close or delete the child
component
by clicking on that close button
now parent component went to update
phase
and jail component went to
unmounting phase
so as a part of the update phase of the
parent component the render method
and at last component did upgrade method
executes for the parent component
and in between that is exactly
after the render method of the parent
component
the chill component went to unmounting
phase
so as a part of that
the component will unmount method has
been executed
as a part of unmounting phase of the
child component
but still we have not seen unmounting
phase of the parent component that is
shopping cat component
because it has to be unwanted from the
parent
who invokes the shopping cart component
that is from app.jsx
but to demonstrate this we really
require
routing
we have not yet added routing in our
application as of now
so let's ignore it
this is how do you understand
parent-child component life cycle
in react
so overall the conclusion is that
each time the child component phase will
be executed after the render method of
the parent component
this is how do you understand the
complete life cycle of parent and jail
components in react
whenever while executing a component
or rendering a component
or
execution of any lifecycle method
or while execution of any constructor of
nhl component
in all these cases
if any exception or runtime error is
raised in that case the component did
catch method automatically gets executed
and that comes under
error handling phase
so suppose you have a component and
while executing that component that is
in the render phase or lifecycle method
or
constructor of hl component
then this component did catch method
automatically executes
which receives two parameters
automatically that is error and info
the first parameter that is error
represents the actual error message
which causes the error
and the second one info
contains the additional information
about the particular error
such as component stack
that means the list of methods that
causes that particular error
see in case if there is no error
this particular method will not execute
so i am adding that method in the
shoppingcat component
that is after component will unmount
method i am adding a method called
componentdid catch
and it contains two arguments that is
error
and info
these will be passed by react
automatically
and let me print that console.log
message
error comma info
so when you run this application
as of now there is no any error
so that method did not execute
as you can see there is no componented
catch method executes for the shopping
cart
but alternatively
let's make some changes
to make it error
suppose in the constructor of the
channel component that is a product
component
let's make some changes for example
instead of this props dot product
i'm just writing
pro-uct where d is missing
so this causes error while executing the
child component that is
product component
which is being invoked as a part of the
shopping cat component
you can add a statement to store that
information in the local storage
so local storage dot last error
equal to
that error
and on the next line we want something
called info
here backslash n represents the next
line character
so we are storing error and info details
in the local storage dot last error
property which will be available in the
same browser
so like this you can write any code in
order to log that information
somewhere in the memory
and we can convert the same into json
format
so that
it will show up the details correctly
so let me add something called
json.stringify
of info
sorry the message must be component did
catch but not component unmount
let's execute this
as you can see whenever react identifies
some error while executing the
constructor of the product
it raises an exception
and
the component did catch method executes
for the parent component
that is shopping cat component
and this is the information of
the first parameter that is error
that means the complete details about
the error
and after that the second argument that
is info is the component stack
that is a list of components that arises
or causes or catches the exception
actually that error was originally
raised in the product component
but has been accelerated to shopping cat
component
and the same has been accelerated to
app.jsx file
and you are going to store the
information of error and info
inside the local storage for future
reference purpose
so
if you can check application
and switch to local storage
you can see the details of last error
along with the corresponding component
stack
like this you can use your component did
cache method
for logging the errors
somewhere in the memory such as local
storage
this is all how to use component cache
method
in your application
and before the next lecture i will be
removing or commenting these console.log
messages in order to keep the browser
console clean
to make it clear to understand further
lectures
here my goal is that to create a login
form
that means overall i would like to
demonstrate how to work with the forms
in react
a form is meant for collecting
information from the user
which includes form elements such as
text box checkbox ready button drop down
list etc
and in react we can use all html tags
to create the form
but here the important point to
understand is
how will you bind the textbox values to
the properties of the component
state let's try
let me create a new component called
login component so right click on src
folder
login.jsx
and we have a component called login
import react and component from react
module
and your render method renders something
such as
a new tag with login
and now
i would like to render this particular
login
from the app.jsx file
instead of rendering shoppingcat
component
don't worry we will invoke the customers
list and shoppingcat component later
when we go to the routing section
so for time being
after the navbar i would like to render
login
which can be imported from
login.jsx file
so import
login from
login.jsx
and by the way we have commented out all
the console.log messages
in all the lifecycle methods that are
demonstrated in the previous section
okay now switch to login.jsx file
here i would like to use
html and bootstrap
to create the login form
i want a bootstrap box with
nine columns
and a heading called login
with margin top
as well as padding
and border bottom
which is rendered like this
and below the heading i would like to
place the email and password text boxes
so
update react.component as just component
as we have imported component earlier
and also in app.jsx file
comment out this shoppingcat component
import statement as we don't require it
for time being
and now in the login.jsx file
create a new tag with form group class
as suggested by bootstrap
a bootstrap form group represents a set
of label and a text box
that represents a specific field
and you would like to place a label
that horizontally occupies four columns
in a row
that is email
and you wish to create actual text box
by using input typing called text
and apply the css class name as form
control
and input is unveiled tag
for clarity let me add comment
where email starts
and comments look like this in react
where it is the javascript comment
along with expression
and here email ends
so
this is your email
and similarly let's apply the same for
password
and input type equal to password
and the label is password
so when you run this
you can see
email and password text boxes in the
form
but here the question is how will you
bind these text box values
to the respective state properties
first let us create necessary state
properties
to store the email and password values
there are two ways to initialize the
state right
one is that
you can directly write like state equal
to object
as we did earlier
the another recommended way is that
initialize the state in the constructor
but in case of constructor
you must call the parent class
constructor
as a first statement
by using super keyword
this will receive the props which are
supplied by the react
and pass the same to the parent class
that is component class
so that overall the properties get
initialized in the current working class
object that is login
so
here you should write like this dot
state is equal to
your state object
and here you require two properties
called email and password
to store or represent the actual value
of the text boxes
and i'm initializing them
with empty codes that is empty string
now i would like to bind these
particular values
into the corresponding text box
so let us write value
actually in the value whatever the value
that you give that gets appear in the
text box
for example
if you try giving abc the same value as
disappears in the corresponding text box
but alternatively you want to fetch the
value from the state property isn't it
so that is the reason you have to bind
it
through a react expression
and ascend the value of this dot state
dot value
that is this.state.email
so it reads up the value of the email
from the state
and assign the same into the
corresponding value property of the text
box
similarly let's assign the same into
value of the password text box
so value equal to
this dot state dot password
and for understanding let's initialize
the email and password properties with
some default values
such as abc8test.com
and password for example abc123
so if we can see these values in the
browser
that means it is working correctly
as you can see
the state values have been displayed in
the text box because
we have assigned the values of the state
into the value property of the text box
so this is how will you bind the text
box values from the state while working
with the react form
but
in the browser console it shows a
warning but it is not an error
that is
failed prop type that is you provided a
value prop
to your form field
without on change handler
that means it is trying to explain that
in order to enable two-way binding we
have to add on change event in the input
field
will solve it in the next lecture by
enabling two way binding
the problem with react is
it supports only one way binding but
doesn't support two-way binding directly
that means you can actually bind the
state into the text box but not in
reverse by default
so there is no out-of-box supports that
automatically retrieves the value of the
text box into the state
so only it is one way binding
wherever or whenever you update the
value of the stage it gets automatically
updated into the text box
for example if you try using set state
and update the value of email
automatically the updated value gets
reflected in the text box
but not reverse
so
rewards must be done manually by
identifying the changes in the text box
by using on change event
and update the state manually by calling
set state method
in that way the reactor developer can
achieve the two-way binding
even though two-way binding is not
supported out of the box
let's see how to do it
so in the input tag that is the email
text box
you need to add a property called
onchange
this event executes whenever change
event occurs in the text box
that means
as soon as the value has been changed in
the text box
so
in this case either you can write an
error function directly inside the
onchange
or you can call a method of the
component
in this case i prefer using an error
function
because we have only one statement
execute
so we don't require a separate method
for that
so
i'm creating an error function
and
in order to get the latest value of the
text box
we use
the synthetic event that is
event parameter that is supplied by the
browser automatically for all the event
handlers
and access the even dot target dot value
so here event is the synthetic parameter
that is supplied by browser
automatically
that contains additional details about
the current working event
for more information you can refer to
any javascript tutorial
that even synthetic parameter is
supplied for all the even handlers by
default
so
based on that synthetic event
your accessing target.value
that automatically represents the latest
updated value of the textbox
so
you need to update the same to the state
property
that is email property here
but can we ascend the value directly by
using state dot email equal to something
no
it is not recommended right
except in the constructor in nowhere
else you should assign the value
directly into the state property
but alternatively always we have to use
set state method
in order to update the value
into the state
so here you are updating the email
property
as even dot targeted value
so that the updated value of the text
box gets updated
in the state dot email property
and let me close the parenthesis here
and let me close under brace
yes so this must work let's check it
as of now
whenever you update the value of the
text box
automatically this particular latest
value whatever you type here
will be automatically updated into the
email property of the state
in order to ensure the same
in the same error function i am writing
another statement
that is console.log of
this dot state dot email
so as you can check here
as soon as you type something here for
example i am trying to type x widget
and click the cursor outside
so you can see the latest value has been
updated into the email property
and notice that setstate method is
asynchronous
so we are not sure that the next
statement that is console.log statement
will execute only after updating the
state
since the set state method is
asynchronous
so
let's clear the browser console
and let's try to type something for
example abcd
you are not seeing the lastly printed
message
that is avcd here because set state
method is by default asynchronous
you don't need to really worry about
this it's a default behavior in react
but still if you have a doubt in that
you can explicitly add a button
and explicitly identify the value of
state dot email
so let's remove the console.log
statement from this error
function and
below the
text box let me add a button
with class name btn and b10 primary as
for bootstrap
and we have something called login
button
and when the user clicks on this login
button we are calling a method called
on loginclick
so
when the user clicks on the login button
we are executing a method called on
login click
that must be present in the same
component
this is end of for render method
so
let me add that on loginclick method
that is an error function
this executes when the user clicks on
login
and here we are printing the latest
value of the state
that is this dot state
and now have a look in the output
so suppose i update something in the
email
let's say xyz
at
something.com
as soon as we have updated the value of
the textbox
this particular value gets updated or
refreshed
in the corresponding state dot email
property
because of on change event
it's because we are using set state
method in the on change event of the
email text box
but we have not added on change event
for the second text box that is password
so password will not be updated
when the text box is changed
let's clear the browser console
and click on the login button
as you can see
email has been changed
but
password has not updated
this value abc123 has been initialized
in the beginning that is in the
constructor itself
so now we are showed that because of
onchange event in the textbox we are
able to get the latest value of the text
box into the state
so let's repeat the same thing that is
on change event for the password text
box also
let's copy paste on change
into password text box
and simply update the property name of
the state that is password
so let's verify this output
now that error has been cleared out of
course
so try to update something for example
squat at testo.com
and password is squad123
so we have updated both values
and we are sure that
as soon as you modify something in the
textbox
that particular value gets updated into
the corresponding state property
whereas the first textbox value into
state dot email
and second textbox value into
state.password
this update will not wait for login
button click
that means
even though we don't click on the button
the values gets updated into the state
property all the time
because we have updated the state dot
property value in the on change event
but not in the click event
so we are using the click event only for
getting us know
that the value has been updated
so let's click on login button now you
can see the latest value of the text
boxes
are visible in the state
that is scott test.com and password is
called one two three
this is how you manually create the
two-way binding in react
whereas if you compare the same thing in
angular kind of frameworks
angular by default supports two-way
binding whereas
react by default supports one-way
binding that is state to form element
but not reverse
where react developer manually should
update the state through on change event
of the form element
so we have to repeat this on change
event for each and every form element
not only for text boxes
but also for check box radio button or
any other form element
but in case if you have additional logic
to perform in the on-chain event
alternatively you can make this as a
separate method in the component
and in that method you can write the
same statement that is this third state
along with your additional logic to
execute
for example every time when the text box
value has been changed you want to make
a http request to server
so you can do that by calling another
method
for the on-chain event
this is how you create two-way binding
in react
suppose the requirement is that
when the user clicks this login button
you want to check whether the email and
password is correct
and show the feedback to the user saying
that either successful login or
invalid login
so when the user clicks on the submit
button
you can access the updated values of the
text box that are entered by user
by using this dot state dot email and
this dot stated password
while writing the code in the button you
need not worry how to get the values
from the actual text boxes
because in the on change event of the
text box we are already updating the
state
so that you can access the latest value
of the text box in the button click
method itself
so
in the login.jsx file
for the due tag let me add text write to
display the button right side
and already we have on click event for
the button
that calls on loginclick method that is
written here
and also in the state
let me make the email and password as
empty string
because we don't want to see the
default values in the text boxes of
login form
and now
in the login click method
let's write your logic for example if
this dot state dot email is equal to
some dummy email for example
admin gmail.com
or admin test.com
and password is admin 123 for example
of course this is a dummy example we are
not connecting to any database in this
application as of now
we will learn to make http requests in
the further sections
but for time being we are checking some
dumb email and dummy password
so if both email and password are
matching
then we have to show a success message
to the user
otherwise some error messages to user
in order to show a message to user what
we have to do
since we cannot show directly on the web
page
we have to create a property called
messages for example
and update your message into that
message property
and then render the message property
somewhere near the button
let's try
let me go to the constructor
and in the state of the component let me
add a property called message
by default it is empty string that is
empty codes
and after that
let me update that message property
after clicking on the button
so in case of success
message ascends to
some value for example successfully
logged in
and i wish the same should be in a green
color so instead of a plain string let
me add a span
with the class name that is
text to success
that means green color as per bootstrap
and in case of error
let me update the message as
invalid login
and that should be appear in red color
that means as per bootstrap
recommendation it is text to danger
class
so at the time of application launching
by default message is empty string
user type something in the text box
and because of onchange
the value gets updated in the
corresponding property of the state
that is either into email or password
depending on the text box
so user updates the email and that gets
updated in the state dot email
user type something in the password
that gets updated in the password
property of the state
and finally he clicks on the button
it calls on loginclick method
by the time already state.email and
stated password contains the updated
values of the text box
that are entered by user
so
directly you can access the updated
values of the text box by using this dot
state dot email and this third stated
password
then you are checking them
with some dummy email and password
and if the condition is true
you are assigning successful login span
tag into message property of the state
otherwise invalid login
sorry i must be using set state method
right
so set state
message property
like this
and similarly in the below statement
also
this dot set state
of the message property
that is sends to the span tag
so this is the correct code
let's check this out
oops there is an error invalid dom
property class
so for the due tag we are using class
instead of class name it must be class
name right
and also it is recommended to use triple
equal to
instead of double equal to for
comparison
of course it is not must to use but
react by default shows a warning
that recommends you to use triple equal
to
i think you know that triple equal to
checks the value as well as type
whereas double equal to checks only the
value but not the type
here email and password are by default
string type
and the value that you mentioned in
codes is also string type
so triple equal to checks both type and
value at both operands
anyways
let's check the output finally
suppose i am typing some wrong email and
wrong password
click on login
as you can see
the latest values are visible in the
console
that is updated from the text boxes
but we have to render the message then
only it's visible to the user right
so near the button
i am rendering the message by using this
dot state dot
message
and i would like to show this message
before the button isn't it
so let me place it
before the button
so we are rendering the message before
the button
and for the button there must be a
margin for example
m1
let's recheck it
again i am trying to type some wrong
email address and wrong password click
on login
so it shows correct message that is
invalid login
and after that
trying to type some correct email
address that is admin at test.com
and password is admin 123
click on login
as you can see it shows successful
messages
here the message property holds a
reference to the react element
that represents the span tag
so as you can see the type is a span
this is how you create simple form in
react
ajax is a technique to send http request
in background
and get the response from the server in
background without refreshing the web
page
first user performs some activity such
as clicking the button
then browser sends a background http
request to server
the server receive the request
process the request such as connecting
to database
and send the response back to the
browser
so the browser executes some code or
function
in the client side
this is how a web page interacts with
the server in these days
to create the server side program you
can use any server technology such as
asp.net mvc or asp.net web api
or node.js or python or java or any
other equivalent
but in this course instead of connecting
to real database
we are using a third party package
called json server which makes a json
file as a database
here json server is extremely helpful
that act as a fake rest api server
which receive the request process the
request
and send the response back to the
browser
in fact json server helps ui developers
to quickly interact with the server
without needing to create separate
server side program either by using
node.js or java or python
let me demonstrate json server
open the command prompt window
and install a package called
json server
and install it globally by using hyphen
g
after that you need to create a folder
to place your database file
here the json file acts as a database
we have a folder called sequel and data
and in this folder let me create a json
file
that acts as a database
so switch back to visual studio code
go to file menu new file
and save the file
and in the save as dialog box
select the folder sql and data
and specify the file name as
react iphone db.json
so this file acts as a database for you
as per the rules of json server package
you must have a json object
that contains your array that acts as a
database table
for example i would like to serve a set
of products
so the array name is products
and it is an array
which contains a set of products
which includes id
product name
price and quantity
similarly you can add any number of
products
but already in the shopping cat
component
we have a set of products right
so i am copying and pasting the same
array
into this particular json file
and we have to add double quotes for
each property name also
like this
so this particular file that is react
db.json file acts as a database by json
server package
so switch back to the command prompt
window
and enter the command
json hyphen server
and what is your name of the database
file
that is
react hyphen
db.json file
and in order to keep the file watch
for file changes
add the option hyphen iphone watch
and also specify the port number as wish
for example
hyphen fn port equal to
5000
so at port number 5000
json server has been started
and you must be able to see this url
called localhost 5000 products
if you copy paste this particular url in
the browser
you must be able to see the list of
products that are present in the json
file
so we have to make the same kind of
request asynchronously through code
in order to make http request from the
react
you can use
either javascript fetch api
and another third-party package called
xcos
but in this course
fetch api is being used
fetch api is one of the standardized api
in javascript to make http requests
it can be used as alternative to xml
http request which was used earlier
for more information about fetch api you
can use the website called javascript
dot info
so instead of having the list of
products directly initialized on the
shopping cart component
let's make a request to the json server
and get the list of products from that
so let me make this products array as
empty
and as of now it will not display any
list of products
so let me switch to
shoppingcat component in app.jsx file
so in the app.jsx file
instead of rendering login component
let's render shoppingcat component
which is imported from the shoppingcat
file
so
now it renders shoppingcat component
as you can see here
and now because the array is empty it
shows nothing in the list of products
so
i would like to fetch the same data from
the json server
it is not recommended to make http
requests in the constructor of the
component
but it is always advisable to make http
requests in the component did mount
method
so go to the component did mount method
of the shoppingcat component
you can make a http request by using
fetch
and
you can specify the url to which you
want to make request
that is
as shown in the command prompt
it is http localhost 5000 and products
so
localhost 5000 slash products
for this url you are making a get
request
yes by default it makes a get request
optionally you can specify
the request type as get request
by writing method equal to get
and by default this switch method
returns a javascript promise
and you can receive the same into a
variable
based on which you can subscribe to
promise
and
you can pass an error function
as soon as the response is restored from
this particular url
this particular error function will be
executed
where the actual response from the
server will be received as a parameter
in this particular error function
so let me show the same response in the
console
here the method called then is used to
subscribe to the promise
that means as soon as the promise is
resolved
it is ready to call this particular
error function which is supplied here
and the actual response value will be
received into this parameter
that parameter name can be anything
and then you are displaying the same
response in the console.log
now let me show the same
every time when you run this application
the browser makes a http request to the
particular products
so i just refresh the page
apart from all other requests
as you can see it makes a request to
products
so the full url is http localhost 5000
slash products
and we made get request
and the response status code is 200
which indicates that successful response
and if you click on response tab
you can see the actual response received
from the server
so i would like to convert the same
response into object array format from
json
and assign the same into products array
see by default it is in json format
we have to convert the same into
products array
to convert the same into json format
we can call a method called json
and it returns another promise
and let us subscribe to the same promise
by using then
so this particular error function will
be executed
as soon as the response has been
converted from
json format into javascript array
so this error function will be executed
after converting the json into object
array
and this error function receives the
list of products
as an area of objects in javascript
so let me print the same in the
console.log
so console.log of products
as you can see
after receiving the response from the
server like this
the same has been converted into
object array format
from json
and the same is visible in the
console.log
so the one what you're going to see here
is that
javascript array
now i would like to finally assign this
into
this dot state dot products
and how will you update the state
so this code set state
i would like to update the
value of products
equal to
the products parameter which is received
from the error function
for avoiding the confusion
i am writing short name prods
that means products
here products is the name of the
property of the state
and
pr yes is the name of the parameter that
is received after converting from json
into object array
so
as you can see here
the list of products loaded from the
http request
have been assigned to products
and as soon as you ascend something into
the state
the render method will be re-executed
right
so at the initial run of the render
method
the product's array is empty
so the map method doesn't execute even
once
but
after receiving the response from the
server since you are calling setstate
method
the component leads to update phase
so during that update phase the same
render method re-executes right
so at that moment the products array has
been assigned to an array
so that the map method executes once for
each product
in that way you can see the updated
output here
this is how to fetch the data from json
server
but isn't it complicated to use two
promises and two subscriptions
and two error functions
which is nested
in order to solve this problem
practically
javascript offers async and await
concept
so with async and debate the same
process can be done more easily with
simplified syntax
async and await uses promises internally
but really makes it easy
to write the code
for example instead of using them here
you can use something called
await
then promise
that means after resolving the promise
this particular event will be satisfied
and the actual response will be returned
into the specified variable
at the left hand
side
so you need to write all this then
function here
and moreover
instead of receiving the promise into a
separate variable and then writing the
await on the next line
you can write the same event keyword on
the left hand side
for the fetch
so that
directly you can receive the response
and print the same on the next line
so this particular subsequent statement
after the average will be executed after
receiving the response from the server
so step one we are making a request by
using fetch
and what kind of request we are making
get request
after receiving the response from the
server
this particular event keyword receives
the response
and assigns the same into the variable
that is present at the left hand side
and after resolving that means after
receiving the response only the
subsequent statements in the same
function will be executed
meanwhile all the remaining statements
will be
waiting that means will be holded
so let's check on the browser console
it is showing an error saying that
cannot use
keyword called avet
outside the async function
it says that the event keyword can be
used only inside the async function
the async function says that
the function must be executed
asynchronously
unlike regular functions
so while creating the component read
bound method
convert the same into
async function
by keeping the async keyword
so let's try again
now you can see the response from the
server
so here response is by default an object
that contains properties such as body
ok
status status text etc
but we are not interested to see all
these details but we want to see the
actual response
that is available in the response.body
but
the response.body is by default of
readable stream type
so
we have to convert this readable stream
into actual response that is actual
object
so in order to read the data from the
readable stream
and convert the same into object array
format
we have to use another promise called
response.json
so the response.json method reads the
data from the readable stream
first it gets the data in the form of
json
and after that the same json will be
converted into a javascript array
and finally it gives you the data in the
form of object array in javascript
that can be ascend into your regular
variable for example products
so to do all this process it has a
promise
and we have to subscribe to the same by
using await
so wherever you want to subscribe to a
promise we can use await
so the subsequent statements execute
after successfully converting the
response body into object array
let me display the same products value
in the console.log
so as you can see now
the data is available in the form of
object array
which is ready to assign into the state
still the output doesn't show anything
because the state dot products is still
an empty array
so we have to assign this array into the
state
by using set state method
so this dot set state
products is equal to the variable called
prods
that is products in short
so
once the function has been converted
into async
you can use the average any number of
times
that means you can use a weight only
inside the async function
the difference between async and await
function is that
the async function says that the
function executes asynchronously
that means
some of these statements may wait until
the promise has been completed
and after completion of the promise only
the subsequent methods should be
executed
for example
by calling the fetch method we are
creating a promise
and after completion of the promise that
means after receiving the response from
the server
then only the value gets ascend into the
response variable
and it proceed to the subsequent
statements
and similarly we have another form is
executed by
response.json function
and after completion of the response
body into object array format
then that particular value will be
assigned into the products variable
which is later is being assigned into
the state
definitely async and await is a better
way of writing the code for working with
the promise
by using fetch api
in this lecture successfully we are
asserting the data into products array
so that you can see all the list of
products
loaded from the database server
that is json server in this case
let's convert this static email and
password into dynamic
by using json server
that means i would like to make a http
request in case of login click and based
on the response i would like to
determine whether it is successful login
or invalid login
so
switch to app.jsx file
instead of shopping cat component
let's render login component
and import login from
login.jsx file
and go to react db.json file
to store the list of users let me add
another array in the david.json file
that is users
along with email and password values
for example we have two users called
scott and ellen
scott gmail.com
[Music]
and scott123
or squattest.com
and every object must be having a
property called id as per the
recommendations of json server
it must be a unique number
so we have two users called scott and
ellen
in the user's array
inside your db.json file
make sure the json server is running
and it shows two urls now that is
localhost 5000 products and users
so you need to make request to this
particular url for the login form
and pass the email and password as
corresponding parameters
then it checks for the matching values
and only returns the matching objects
instead of passing all as response
so
now switch back to the login.jsx file
and i'm trying to use async and await
here
so that is
first convert this function into async
function so that you are eligible to use
avet keyword here
where response equal to
await
fetch of
the url that is
localhost 5000
slash users
and you have to concatenate your
email and password values from the state
for easier concatenation let me use
backtick operator in ecmascript
so that you can concatenate the email
and password easily
that is email equal to
you can interpolate the email value by
using dollar and then braces
and supply the actual value
so in this place the actual value from
the state dot email will be substituted
so overall it means that the json server
should return the data from the user's
array only when the email is matching
with the supplied value
but we have to check the password also
right
to supply another parameter we use
ampersand in the query string
and supply the other parameter name
that is password
and fill the actual value that is state
dot password
so
we are trying to make a get request for
this particular url
and it returns the corresponding user
object
that is matching with the specified
email and password
if the email and password doesn't match
it returns an empty array
so after receiving the response from the
server
the response will be ascend into the
response variable
and after that the subsequent statement
will be continued
but you need to read the response body
convert the json object into a
javascript object by using response.json
method
after successfully converting the json
object into a javascript object or
javascript array
this particular promise will be resolved
so that is the reason
we are using await keyword here
now the body variable represents the
actual response body that is received
from the server
now we have to check the condition that
is
if
some body is received
that means at least one object is
received
then we have to say that it is
successful login
in case if the array is empty array
it means it is invalid login
for information let me print the
console.log of body
so that you can see the response body in
the console
let's run this application
make sure the json server is running in
background
i am entering some wrong email and wrong
password
and click on
login
and this is the response body that is
empty array since the email and password
is invalid
but it shows successfully logged in
because we have to check the length of
the array
so if the response body length is
greater than 0
that means at least one object is found
in the array
then only it has to say successful
otherwise invalid
now i am entering the wrong email
address and wrong password again
click on login
you got the same response since the
email and password doesn't match on the
database.json file
so this time it shows invalid login
messages
but next time i am trying to enter
squat test.com
and squat123
then click on login
it says successfully logged in
because this time the response body is
an array with one object
that is the data loaded from the
database.json file
so since there is at least one object
the if condition is true
so
since the if condition is true here
we are updating the successful login
message in the message property
so it shows the correct output here
this is how to make your login form
dynamic by making http request
and in case if you want to retrieve the
data conditionally or unconditionally we
have to use get request
for inserting the data into server we
use post request
for updation of data on the server we
use put request
and for deletion of the data from the
server we use delete request
and when we use all these types of
requests that is get post put and delete
that is called
restful service or restful
implementation
that is why we call it as restful
services
routing is a mechanism that maps between
a component and url
for example it maps like
whenever the url is slash dashboard
i would like to open the dashboard
component in this place
so let us learn how to do it
first switch to app.jsx file
in this case i would like to make one
more component that is dashboard
component
and the dashboard component should be
opened after successful login
so let me create a new file called
dashboard.jsx
and let's create a dashboard component
and i would like to invoke this
particular dashboard component
in the app.jsx file
so as of now
instead of login i am trying to invoke
the dashboard component
and import dashboard
from dashboard.jsx file
and it's working here
but the same should run through routing
in order to work with the react routing
we need a package called react router
dom
so switch to command prompt
and locate your application folder that
is sql and react my first app
and install a package called react
router dom
and add hyphen f1 save
so that this particular package name
gets added into the package.json file
after installing the package
import all the components that are
necessary for routing
that includes login form
and shopping cat
and also the customers list
and then import route from router
package
now import browser router
from react router dom
now instead of rendering react.fragment
render something called browser router
which helps us to render any one of the
routes available
or in other words
browser router enables routing in our
entire application
and first you are rendering the navbar
that means the navigation bar
after that
any one of dashboard shopping catch and
customers should run right
so
play something called route
and specify the path
so you need to map for which path which
component should be executed
for example in case if the path is equal
to slash
and exactly it is equal to slash
in that case you want to execute the
component called
login component
initially the url will be slash so that
automatically picks up login
let's run this
as you can see
the empty url that is localhost to 3000
is understood as
slash
so this url is equivalent to slash in
that case the login component executed
on the screen
similarly we can add necessary routes
for other pages such as dashboard
shopping cache and customers
so in case if the url is dashboard
component is dashboard component
and for customers
customers component
that is customers list component
and if the url is cat
then the component should be shopping
catch component
the property called exact is optional
but it enables us to render the
component only if the url is exact match
if you don't add exact for example if i
remove exact for the cat
for all the urls that begins with cat
it renders the shopping cat component
for example
even if the url is cat slash
something
in that case also the shopping cat
component will be executed
to avoid such situation
we use something called exact as a
property for every route
so let's run this
so in case of slash login component
in case of dashboard
dashboard component
and in case of cat
shopping cat component
and in case of customers customers
component is working
so based on the url changes the
corresponding page or component gets
opened
here each component acts as a page
or you can say it's a part of the page
because in the whole app component
we are loading a component
that is any one of these components
depending on the url
so this is the routing that we have
created which maps for each url a
specific component
but
what if the user has entered a different
url which does not exist at all
for example he is typing something like
this
which does not exist at all in our
routing configuration
in that case apart from the navbar it
renders nothing
because
this particular url doesn't match with
any one of the routes that is defined in
the app.jsx file
so for that case you can define another
component
and that is called 404 page or 404
component
you can really give it any name
so let's create a new file that is
no matchspace.jsx
and let's create a component
that is no match page
and some text like page not found
so i would like to execute this
particular page
whenever the user has entered a wrong
url
in that case
go to app.jsx
and specify the path as star
means asterisk
which matches with any other url other
than the above mentioned
in short asterisk indicates all
so it matches with anything
and for this we cannot add exact
because it should match with any url
not only just asterick
and specify the component name as
no match page
which can be imported from
no match page.jsx
and now
whenever the user has entered some wrong
url something like this
it automatically opens the no match page
after the nav bar
always nav bar is constant because we
have rendered it
outside the routing
so always it renders nav navbar
unconditionally
and
any one of the routes execute based on
the url
but there is a practical problem here
suppose if the url is customers
of course it renders the customers page
but after that at the end
it is even rendering the no match page
which you don't expect
it's because
the url customers even matching with
this asterisk
so
since asterisk matches with all urls
it always renders the no match page
even for above urls that is dashboard
customers and cat
so overall your goal is that
you want to execute either of these only
you don't want to execute multiple
for that case we use something called
switch
i will be demonstrating switch in the
next lecture
so we need to keep all these routes
inside the switch tag
so that any one of the routes only will
execute at any cost
no routes will execute at a time
now we got narrowed saying that switch
is not defined
so let's import switch from react router
now as you can see
if the url is customized it loads the
customers page but
no match page doesn't execute unlike
earlier
in the same way if the url is cat
only it executes the shoppingcat
component
no match page doesn't execute
and in the same way dashboard
and login pages are working
only when the url is unknown
that means other than the specified
routes
in that case only no matching page
executes
that is the use of the switch
so switch ensures that any one of the
routes only will execute
in no case multiple components will
execute
now i would like to create the
navigation links in the navigation bar
for dashboard customers and the shopping
cat
so switch to the
navbar.jsx file
already we are placing something called
home
inside the nav bar
so let me make it as login
and instead of using the a tag
we have to use something called the link
tag in order to create the hyperlink
for react router
so why not the html anchor tag
why should we use the link tag
because the browser makes a request to
server
as soon as the user clicks on the
hyperlink
but
we should not make a request right
alternatively we have to load the
component in the same page then only
this application can be single piece
application
so in order to avoid sending a request
to server
but alternately react has to handle that
routing
and load the corresponding component
into the switch
for this case we use link
but what are the classes that can be
used on the regular hyperlink tag
all of those css classes can be
applicable even for link
so that you can assume your link tag as
anchor tag of html
but instead of writing the address in
the href attribute
we have to write the same in the two
so
instead of a hrf you are writing link
two
and here you will specify the actual url
that means the route path
that route path should match with these
route paths that are defined in the
switch
for example you want to create hyperlink
to login
so it must be slash
so in the nav bar i'm writing link to
slash
and specify the css class name now
hyphen link
just for styling purpose
similarly let's repeat the same syntax
for all the remaining hyperlinks
that is customers
shopping cat
and also dashboard
let me place the dashboard at the first
and fill the urls as a slash dashboard
slash customers
slash cat
so this path must match with the path
that you mentioned in the app.jsx file
and also we have to import link from
router
so import link
from react iphone router
sorry it is react router dom
so these are the hyperlinks that are
created here
let's run this
as you can see you click on login
dashboard
customers shopping cat
all are working fine
and there is a starting issue here
all hyperlinks are by default rendered
line balance
in order to make them horizontal
we have to place this inside the la tag
right
so let me place this link tag inside the
la tag with the class name now hyphen
item
and after that open another la tag
let me repeat the same for all
now it's correctly placed
now as you can see login dashboard
customized shopping cache is working
when the user clicks on any of these
router links browser doesn't make any
request
but alternatively react handles that
route path
and based on the path that is mentioned
in the app.jsx file
the corresponding component gets loaded
inside the switch place
so in that way first nav bar be constant
and after that any one of these selected
components will be executed
and let's go to login.jsx file
let me remove this class name call lg9
and also
customerslist.jsx file
this is fine
and then shopping cat component
remove this class name called container
fluid
and then
product.jsx file
here
add div class equal to row
and wrap the entire content inside this
particular div tag
so close the new at the end of the
render method
so now all the pages are working fine
that is login
dashboard customers shopping cat
now switch back to app.jsx file
place a due tag with class name
container fluid
and place this new tag before the switch
that means place the switch tag inside
the container fluid
so as per the recommendations of
bootstrap
container fluid is required
in order to make the content look center
of the page
and avoid the alignment issues
and then go to product component
here avoid placing row
and delete the corresponding closing tag
all right
now the login page dashboard customers
shopping cat all the components are
working fine
but to be frank this is not enough for
building real world react applications
you will really require to know the
functional components
and also advanced concepts such as redax
and that is where you will check out my
full course on udemy
that is complete react ultimate guide
in this course we are going to build the
full pledged e-commerce application
along with red x
redex toolkit
router and bootstrap
in this udemy course we are going to
learn the complete react with class
components as well as functional
components
for example if you can check this
section of course project with hooks
here we are going to learn various hooks
such as use state use effect validations
use callback
and many more advanced features of react
hooks
and importantly context api
and additionally in this course we are
going to learn red x react redux redex
thunk red x promise radix saga
and many more latest features
and moreover in order to properly
understand all these concepts of react
and red x
one should have the proper knowledge on
javascript concepts
especially functions and objects
so in this udemy course we have provided
the prerequisites of javascript
that is javascript functions and objects
and also ecmascript 2015 classes
so even though you have less or basic
knowledge on javascript
you need not worry in this udemy course
we have covered all the basic concepts
of javascript that are necessary to
understand this react android x
and this is the advanced version of
e-commerce application that we are going
to build in the udemy course
see after entering the essential email
and password
we have the dashboard page
where the user can see his previous
orders
and the products in the cart
from there he can buy the product or
delete the item in the cart
and if you click on the store page
you can see all the available products
you can filter out them
the products and brands which you don't
want
you can select a particular product and
add to cart
and the same is visible in the cart
itself
and from there you can either buy or
delete
so this is the application that we are
going to build with react hooks in the
udemy codes